the democrats have tried to expand
abortion in the united states pretending
as though it was the codification of roe
v wade it wasn't what they actually
proposed was a serious expansion and it
was blocked because joe manchin was like
nah this is an expansion that would do
away with like 500 different laws it's
not codifying what already exists and
he's right i mean you take a look at
what they're proposing and it would
allow third trimester abortion under the
pretext of health but there's a really
interesting question about that if it
says after viability so you're basically
saying the baby is healthy and capable
of surviving on its own viable but you
can kill it if the mother is sick
so this was a very uh rigid expansion a
very serious expansion it's not going to
make it through now you've also got some
republicans offering up some kind of
pro-choice bill i guess you can call
pro-abortion bill but the argument is
that susan collins says they need their
own version because this version they
tried to pass didn't provide exemptions
for catholic or christian hospitals to
not perform the abortions so
everything's just a mess double
standards from the left and joe manchin
quite literally was just like you can't
expand it if you want to cut a fight you
do so it's not happening and so this of
course is resulting in more outrage more
anger more protest protesters of course
descended on nancy pelosi's home after
she praised it so i can only say i guess
you reap what you sow granted nancy
pelosi is not a member of the court so
it's not illegal to protest there
probably just unethical and then we got
inflation it's really bad it was 8.3 and
many of these news outlets were like
that shows signs of cooling off
except that's an opinion which shouldn't
be in a news piece and with diesel
prices at record highs and diesel
shortages on the way now being reported
expect next month's reporting on
inflation to be
terrifying but i'm sure most of you are
already feeling it because you can't get
baby formula and um
hold on
if you're a conservative woman you can't
get baby formula but but if you're a
liberal woman you can't get cat food
i'm being for real cat food and baby
formula so i'm like it's hitting both
sides
everybody has cats i have a cat i'm just
kidding i'm just being a jerk anyway i
don't have a cat we're going to talk
about all this i don't i ain't no
liberal woman i don't have the cap but i
can be
yeah
i want it if i decide
joining us to discuss ultra maga and
other things is julio rosas
how are you doing how's it going man all
right who are you uh just some guy
some guy though how'd you get in here
oh i know how to get into places it's
kind of in my dna oh wow okay strong
start julio well you're on start you
have a book yes yeah oh yeah that's
right
yeah
i wrote a book fiery but mostly peaceful
the 2020 rights and gas lighting of
america it came out last week two years
in the making officially talking about
all the riots that i covered in 2020 and
even a little bit into 2021 uh and
detailing my experiences but also the
experiences of people who were impacted
by it which surprisingly you know
shockingly was quite a lot of people
uh unfortunately and so
you know i really wanted to
you know i didn't i didn't when
everything started back in may i didn't
go into thinking i'm going to write a
book about about this but
as they continued and as uh you know
they would get worse and then you see
the media coverage and how slander that
was and someone who was there i was in a
very unique position to be to say well
no this is how it actually went and then
the other half of it was
all my work
is on it's on twitter it's on town hall
where i work
uh but as we've seen with big tech and
kind of the instability with social
media as it is
i wanted to have a physical medium out
so that it's uh it is oral history uh
for for this very tumultuous time fiery
but mostly peaceful yeah all right man
cool thanks for coming we also got
sheamus
i am here tonight i run a youtube
channel called freedom tunes we're going
to be releasing another cartoon tomorrow
this one is going to be on roe v wade i
think you all are going to enjoy it and
i am excited to talk to you about this
book because i think a lot of people
have forgotten just how terrifying the
summer of 2020 was it was almost as if
as soon as it happened we forgot about
it yeah i'm excited to talk about it too
i i had the feelings like why did he not
send in the national guard on day two i
don't know what your thoughts are maybe
we'll get into it on the show yeah ian
crossland great to be here and i am also
here i'm not a liberal woman but i do
have a cat he is a wonderful cat he's
like a dog he'll come sit with you while
you're sick if you want to see pictures
of him i have a bunch on my instagram
which is sour patch letterman hold on
he'll sit with you when you're sick yeah
he knows when you're sick after i get my
mri he'll come and chill with me he's
waiting for me to die i know so he can
eat my eyeballs i still love cats
don't assume positive motivation when
you're dealing with cats
all right everybody before we get
started head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and pick up
your ageless multi-collagen this is
collagen it is what you need for your
joint hair skin and nails and uh for me
i skate all the time exercising almost
every single day so this stuff is really
great i am 36 so i definitely got to
make sure my joints and bones are
working and we added a new seven foot
quarter pipe it's almost it's basically
two vert which means you go up really
really high and i've crashed a few times
but thanks to this age just
multi-collagen my bones are stronger
than ever
i don't know if that's true i just know
that it does help because my knees do
hurt head over to stronger bones and
life.com and you will get a 60-day
money-back guarantee 51 off the healthy
aging support of collagen and its ideal
forms five key types of collagen you
need from four different sources for
every order today they will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org it's biotrust of
course to date biotrust has provided
over 5 million meals to hungry kids
police help biotrust hit their goal of 6
million meals this year it is non-gmo
and free of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and rbst
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth and other collagen supplements
there's no clumping unlike other
supplements and you'll get free shipping
with every order free vip live health
and fitness coaching from biotrust team
of expert nutrition and health coaches
for life with every order and their free
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
so head over to strongerbonesandlife.com
to pick up your biotrust ageless
multi-collagen shout out to biotrust for
sponsoring the show
and don't forget head over to
timcast.com and become a member to help
support our journalists to get access to
exclusive segments from this show monday
through thursday at 11 p.m we will have
a members only uncensored
unfamily-friendly show up at 11 p.m as i
said but there's a big reason why you
should become a member as a member
you are helping support alternative
infrastructure in big tech because we
recently moved over the entirety of the
website our video hosting to rumble's
infrastructure now rumble's not perfect
of course but it's competition for
silicon valley more companies need to do
the same thing we are doing we're the
only ones truth social is also on
rumble's infrastructure this is what we
all need to do support companies that
are using infrastructure from alternate
tech sources we've got major
announcements because we are still
working on new infrastructure so that we
can tell these big tech far left cult
silicon valley people to screw off and
they can't cancel us with your support
we'll make news
we will
produce news and we'll also make the
news with the new infrastructure so
again timcast.com and smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you really do like it and
let's read the big news from timcast.com
senate republicans and mansion block
women's health protection act quote make
no mistake it is not roe v wade
codification it is an expansion it wipes
500 state laws off the books said
senator joe manchin so let's just do
this
that's simple the democrats were acting
like this was going to be federal
codification of roe v wade that's not
true and i will just go straight to it
with section 4 of the bill which is 3755
which states there can be no limitations
or requirements on
a prohibition on abortion after fetal
viability when in the good faith medical
judgment of the treating health care
provider continuation of the pregnancy
would pose a risk to the pregnant
patient patient's life or health i just
want to pause real quick and assess that
provision right there and just say
it says after viability meaning the baby
can survive
you're saying you can
terminate the baby
even if it could survive
because the mother's health may be at
risk i understand if their argument is
end the pregnancy if it said and the
pregnancy but preserve the life of the
baby but it didn't say that quite
literally they're like we can kill a
baby if the woman would be medically
harmed by the pregnancy why not why not
just take the baby out and let it lift
maybe they're assuming that if the
removal of the baby would kill the woman
then but either way they're gonna have
to take the body out whether it's alive
or not exactly also um
this idea of an exemption for health
this is a term which is used very
vaguely so they're actually able to say
something along the lines of well we
have determined that this woman might be
negatively affected with respect to
something like depression if she has a
child therefore
the abortion is a medical necessity
i i think it's just they need to meet
their blood quotas for to sacrifice the
molecule yeah that's all it is yeah yeah
blood quotas to moloch
but i think
i think it has to be in person so i
don't know if it would count
yeah bloodlust is no joke
that's from eating all the animal meat
i don't think so there are a lot of
people who eat animal eat that don't
raise real fast yeah
i have humans i'm just
[Laughter]
can you tell if this meant like if the
woman would die if the baby was taken
out of the body at eight months or is
this like if the woman would survive if
the body faster viability it's the
weirdest thing what is viability it
means the baby can survive on its own
without like a breathing apparatus or
like an incubator or something there are
humans that are considered viable humans
that need a breathing apparatus
viability just means the baby can
survive without the mother at this point
maybe that does mean they got to put it
in an icu and a respirator or something
i just i really don't get the argument
that it's like
this baby could survive
but we should kill it i don't i
genuinely don't get it i don't
understand i mean it's the purpose
though when you think about it because
most people they're not they're not
going out and having an abortion because
they feel as if something is living off
their body that they don't want to live
off their body it's because they don't
want to be a parent so viability or
non-viability isn't really a relevant
argument to them i mean but it also just
speaks to why they haven't actually gone
forward i mean this could have they
could have codify it for the past 50
years but they're not going to because
it puts democrats in this weird position
on where exactly
they draw this line and clearly they
they drew the line joe's like so far
out of field that
we get someone like joe manchin mansion
is
like he is the savior of the democratic
party
they the reason they don't codify roe v
wade is that they need it as a wedge
issue so all of a sudden joe manchin
comes along and he's like oh i can't do
it and all the democrats are like we're
trying but joe manchin won't let us
keep trying exactly exactly and the
republicans do the same thing they did
it with obamacare they could have
repealed it but they were like no no no
don't do it don't do it it riles people
up so do you think it's convenient for
them that joe manchin is standing in the
way or do you believe that he is
actually actively trying to impede it
for that reason uh i i i think it's a
perfect storm look joe mentions a west
virginia democrat which means he's got
to be moderate to right leaning on these
issues exactly if but i i got to be
honest i don't see joe manchin getting
re-elected that just sounds insane to me
at this point
west virginia went like 86 percent for
trump
this dude i just don't see it so he
might just be like i'll play my role you
know make give the democrats a chance to
keep complaining about these things and
never do anything about it i uh pulled
up an article from washington post that
says fetal viability is generally
considered to be around 23 or 24 weeks
which is like what is that five to six
months and uh there's no universal
consensus some hospitals will
resuscitate the baby actively treat
babies born in 22nd week so it's
somewhere around there i don't know
where they got this data but this is
washington post so i can understand if
there's a baby that's considered viable
at a certain age and the mom's like
dying for some reason and they're like
we're gonna we're gonna abort the
pregnancy and then the baby dies i'm
like okay well you know these things
happen they're trying to save life i
just don't understand the idea that they
don't explain that they don't break it
down there's no there should be
limitations there it should be that it
should include that provision and an
attempt to save the life of the baby
should be there's a big difference
between six-month viability and
eight-month viability that you're like a
human being ready to just bounce outside
the skin at nine months so like yeah i i
don't know the word viability is very
weird because if the power goes out then
what does that word even mean anymore
so if a baby is born at eight months but
they need to be hooked up to a
respirator or breathing machine and the
power goes out could you make the same
argument you'd have to say like well we
don't have we don't have a breathing
machine can this thing survive on its
own with modern technology which in this
theoretical should be no electricity
what is it called uh what's this what's
the pump they call it put on your face
and pump it it's like a it's a breast
respirator mask the pump the pump face
mask yeah pump face mask that's exactly
it that's the medical term actually it's
true but they could put that on the baby
yeah so if you if oxygen goes out then
you need to figure something else out
and one of the options would be this
mask that they use when they're
performing resuscitation when they're
performing cpr they use this
it's a handheld mask to perf to deliver
breaths to someone so you can help
someone breathe if the power goes out
you just need to do it are republicans
going to try and do the inverse and ban
abortion federally that's a good
question i'm not sure yeah i mean i hope
so but i think the republican party is
really pretty weak
but i mean i mean the whole point of roe
versus weight is that it gives it back
to the state so i mean
yeah or returning it um so i mean
ultimately that would i mean because i
mean that's the whole reason why we're
kind of in this mess in the first place
in terms of the this freakish outrage
and them going to supreme court justice
house because they there's this
misconception that
roe v wade ends and then all of a sudden
there's no more abortions just anywhere
and and so i think at least on the state
on the state level obviously a place
like not like california is not going to
do that because it's just so
heavily down but
you would think
that the states would that are
republican controlled so then maybe then
republicans on the federal level
wouldn't feel that pressure necessarily
i think
this attempt right here i mean democrats
just lost any any any i guess the idea
is we tried to do it but because of
mansion you better go vote which i just
don't see being reality they're making
it about the filibuster yeah
well they couldn't get best filibuster
anyway
exactly pointless it's pointless well
then that's because they they always
just fall back to the filibuster because
they have no other thing to to fall back
on when when their things fail
so was there a filibuster involved in
this process that nope they just didn't
get the votes yeah but even if they did
the filibuster would allow they would
need 60 votes it's not going to happen
so there was this really funny thread
from politico where
this democrat was talking about the
economy
and giving a speech to other democratic
party members and politicians and it was
like the other democrats were shocked
and they were like but nothing this is
not coming up in the polls like who
cares about inflation in the economy
and they were like trying to explain to
them it's the economy stupid but you
actually have democrats who are sitting
there right now being like if there's
one thing every american truly cares
about this election it's abortion
meanwhile there's a guy like i have no
gas and they're like but abortion
another person goes i'm hungry yes yes
but abortion and then someone says
there's no baby formula you could have
aborted
it's like is that
fair it's their argument and and not
only abortion right so i've said before
i mean it's all murder but if you're
gonna look at the perspective of your
average american person there are even
many people who would consider
themselves to be in favor of it or or
not in favor of banning it who would say
nine months that's pretty insane but
that's the hill that they're choosing to
die on right now we're we're more we're
more less restrictive than than europe i
mean i mean we had that whole you know
funny clip of bill maher this week
saying i didn't know this did you know
this and his panels were no we didn't
know about europe about how more
restrictive they are bill bill maher has
made his the it's so sad
you know the end of his career is
basically like are you guys hearing
about this thing that happened years ago
i just found out about this thing called
the google it's like bill bill we had
the conversation about europe two months
ago
this dude doesn't have google he is
never heard of he has rules new rule
yeah
new rule everyone you need to google
search something before you talk about
it on your show okay let's give bill
credit he is just the human version of
microsoft explorer there it's fine
that's not a big deal i wanted to you
mentioned that abortion is murder
technically it's not it's just a type of
killing right now but just just for
specifics
you could if you want to be pedantic you
feel like it's murder but it's legally
not murdered
i mean everyone that was killed in the
holocaust was murdered it's even though
it was legal it's like uh you could
argue that too but yeah i mean murder is
a specific legal definition
it's like when stewie on family guy said
it's not that i want to kill lois it's
that i don't want her to be alive
anymore
i want her not to be alive no so murder
is if i understand an unlawful killing
and i'm saying the law of our nation
might not protect those lives but that's
no law at all
yeah i say you understand you think it
is murder but legally it's not
our country our country's laws are not
recognized yeah that's what our laws are
wrong that's the whole problem and the
this is why it doesn't recognize it as
such i think it's really stupid to
define murder as unlawful but i
understand why they would because the
death penalty they would like they argue
is legal but i still think you could
call all of these things murder like the
intentional killing of another person
war is where it's like those they're not
murderers and war they're they're
killers but they're not murderers
ah
i think they're all murderers ah man no
way no if you're protecting yourself and
someone's attacking you you're not
successful yeah but i think i think the
point is ian so if you if you like the
english we're in the ussr putting people
up against the wall technically that was
legal right but i wouldn't say oh
they're not a murderer because that was
legal that person's still this is a good
point i would say maybe it's the the um
aggressive
intentional killing of another person
even then war like you go into a a
like a machine gun nest and wipe
everybody out with a grenade
intentionally based yeah that's that's
not murder you're killing for a living
you know that is an interesting point i
wonder i wonder where we could find the
like where's the actual line and what
would what would be a murder sure i mean
but i i would still definitely say an
innocent unborn child if you kill them
you fall out of the category you made an
excellent point that a government could
make it legal and then do it and it say
hey it's not murder because we made it
legal but like just because it's legal
doesn't mean it's right or good exactly
exactly well if you look at like
abortion china i dare say that the
mountains of skulls there and in like
pol pots cambodia would say a different
story because those were technically
just victims of the government it wasn't
really a murder right i mean yeah
was victim of the government was even
victory right it wasn't even victim well
they wouldn't say they were victims it
was necessary
cleansing of of undesirables everybody
wants to justify why they get to kill
somebody exactly that's suspicious
i understand war though
in times of war consider everything out
the window you want to talk about your
rights good luck when you're in a war
you can talk all day and night about the
rights you do have and i think a person
has inalienable rights
but someone with force can try to
infringe upon those rights and you'll
have to fight for them that's why that's
why i thought it was funny when i was in
the marine corps and going through the
training because we were taught the
geneva conventions and the rights that
we had under that and and we're i'm just
thinking
who would actually
recognize recognize that
no one's gonna recognize that i mean if
we're truly going up against an enemy
that that hates us i was talking about
vietnam the other day and i brought the
my lie massacre i don't know if you guys
are aware it was like one of the
greatest
massacres perpetrated by american troops
ever in the history of the united states
it was like i think 500 vietnamese
villagers women children were burned
alive and killed by like
a hundred troops like a bunch of yeah it
was it wasn't like 20. it was yeah it
was a bunch of them i think helicopter
gun ships were mowing people down i
think it was a company only one guy got
in trouble william law's cali jr he was
a lieutenant and uh they charged him
with like life in prison multiple life
in prison three days later nixon
commuted his sentence and sends him to
house arrest and then he never really
got no one got in trouble for it because
it's like when you're at war the geneva
convention is out i mean for the most
part out the window you do you got to do
to survive these guys had snapped
psychologically and took it out on the
villagers but like you put them in the
jungle and you make them go crazy how
can you really blame them for it i don't
know that's a tough question let me pull
up this story we got from the daily mail
austrian clinic that ships abortion
pills to the us claims it has received
thousands of calls from women especially
in southern states wanting to stock up
on the drug after scotus's roe v wade
ruling was leaked
you know what's crazy about this
in the bill the democrats tried to pass
it says there can be no restrictions on
abortion via telemedicine
tell them i was like how do you do
abortion over the phone they prescribe
your pills
to terminate the pregnancy i wonder
what's going to happen seriously with
the illegal distribution of abortion
pills i mean people are gonna do it
right women are going to they're doing
it now already is the government gonna
send out you know state troopers or
federal police to go and arrest these
women for ordering stuff are abortion
pills gonna be treated like like crack
cocaine or something yeah it's a good
question i'm not sure what the exact
surrounding legislation is going to be i
know according to some figures i've seen
there was as much as a 60 decline in the
rate of abortions in texas so we know
that restrictions will prevent them from
occurring in some number of instances
and they are pretty effective but of
course there are going to be some people
who find a way around the law yeah of
those what do we say 60 reduction that's
what i saw those are the numbers a lot
of those just might be unreported
abortions happening now that aren't
being reported
to a neighboring state numerically it
can be tricky let's uh agree let's let's
have the uh um
feminist triggering conversation should
men be allowed to abort their father
their paternal
responsibilities in a world in which
there's unfettered abortion
so let me let me phrase obviously i
think the more conservative people would
say no fathers should not abandon their
kids under the pretext that women
do let's say the law is passed
abortion up to nine months is legal
would you also need to codify that men
could be like i hereby abort my
responsibility
i mean lydia as a woman
i'm not entirely sure about that i was
just thinking about that that is an
interesting question i do think that if
a mother has the right
so-called from the emanations and
numbers of the constitution that's right
to execute their poor unborn child that
a father should definitely have some say
in whether he has to support a baby i
don't know the idea is if it's like my
body my choice and it's like
okay
if you then choose to have a baby
and you could choose not to which means
killing the baby then it is much less
morally ambiguous for a father to say i
choose not to have a baby because he's
not killing at that point well i think
what's absolutely true about this is
when something like abortion is
legalized and normalized you do see a
breakdown of the family so if a woman
does not have the obligation to care for
her own unborn child what obligation
does a man have to care for his child
and
i think that there's a sort of
consistency there but then i would also
say that it's a consistency towards the
direction of evil and two wrongs don't
make a right ultimately if fathers were
able to abandon their children after
they impregnated a woman without there
being any potential ramification or any
way for her to sue for child support we
would probably see even more abortions
but how how many progressive or liberal
women do you think would advocate for
men having the right to say i have
nothing to do with this baby hmm
that's a good question many yeah well
they they would want the child support
they would say you owe me money well and
that's why it's so funny when liberals
are at you know this past week have been
saying well well then if you're going to
force them to have to have kids and then
the father has to be just as involved
and all the conservatives are saying yes
absolutely no but i know it's just
people arguing it's like it's what
again it just shows just how kind of
we're and obviously it's not just
limited to abortion it happens with
every single topic but the people just
talk past each other and they don't
really know what the other side well i
actually want i i i it is the rule
it is a tendency of the right to not
know the left's argument but the rule is
they typically they should say they
typically do and it is the rule on the
left they don't know the rights argument
that's why the left there's this meme
going around where it's like it's for us
a four panel comic where someone says my
religion says i can't do this and the
person says good for you then the person
says my religion says you can't do this
and they say f off and i'm like you
realize that means no gay marriage in
churches and no abortions at religious
hospitals because if you're saying okay
to someone who says my religion says i
can't do this no cakes for you
no no bait no no gay message cakes no
trans cakes
no abortions at religious hospitals and
no marriages at churches that say no
they clearly don't agree with that they
don't even know their own arguments no
they literally don't know whatever
well also the thing that i love about
this is all of these hot takes about how
men should have to take care of their
children if they get a woman pregnant
they'll tweet something like well if
abortion isn't legal then
a man who gets a woman pregnant has a
responsibility to stay with her and care
for the child like it sounds like
something me disguised as a liberal
would say like hey guys you know what i
think i i think these men should have an
obligation to take care of the child
that they make and they're like yeah
that's just marriage
exactly i i think if if the man gets her
pregnant then he should swear an oath
till death do them part and you know
what i think he should financially
provide for her and she should have the
opportunity to stay home and raise that
child i think she should be at home
raising that child if
if concerned about abortion then we have
to have traditional
like oh no anything but that your terms
are acceptable and they're arguing on
your behalf for the next step of your
argument
that's why it's like guys
these the the pro-choice side which is
to i mean like the literal traditional
liberal types who are sitting there
confused like shrugging
uh they're left out of this and the
overt pro-abortion side which is like
late term
terminate the baby whatever
they don't even know what they're
arguing against they're so far left they
can't see where the right is so they've
looped back and said traditional
marriage must be enforced if you take
away our rights so there's this idea
called horseshoe theory i've coined the
term i call this merry-go-round theory i
think eventually they just go so far to
the left that they get to the right but
then they keep going back around to the
left it's not like they stay at a
reasonable position someone in the chat
actually said sheamus three rights make
a left
[Laughter]
so when you when you get to three
exactly that's the magic number it's
it's kind of remarkable how the left has
gone so far left they've become racial
identitarians
where they're actually just like now
advocating for segregation and they've
begun advocating for traditional
marriage as a point against
conservatives who want it's like we'll
show you going around again
merry-go-round theory when i thought i
think the center stays there just like
watching it happen like
the biggest part well the biggest part
of the question is do you want the
babies to be able to be killed or not
maybe for certain people but i think
it's do you want the government involved
in these decisions and yes if the i've
always thought child support made sense
like if a dad if a guy goes out and gets
five women pregnant and then he just
goes off to santa barbara and to live on
the beach and smoke pot like he has you
know he did some he's created like he
has to follow through with what he's
done if women have the right to
terminate the pregnancy and the man says
i'm out then they have a choice to say
okay me too
so this is this is the point yeah
explain that a little bit i'm not i
don't quite understand if women have the
absolute right to end a pregnancy
because it's their body then there is no
legal argument for the man having any
responsibility at all
the woman gets pregnant she says this is
your fault you got me pregnant he says
you could always choose to get rid of it
have a nice day and leave oh we'd have a
lot of unmarried pregnancies and and i
got to be honest i think the left would
actually be okay with that i think in
the long run yeah they would adopt that
position because ultimately they'll
support anything that denigrates the
family or familial responsibility but
there was a meme that said the reason
they won't accept that position is
because it takes power away from the
woman
if the woman gets pregnant she gets to
choose whether or not the man is is
going to provide her or not
right so with marriage you have two
people who have to make an agreement
with the current laws
the woman can choose to terminate the
baby or keep it and the man has no
choice whatsoever
so pro-choice people are not pro-choice
they're
pro-half
they're pro-abortion they're pro-voting
because if they were pro-choice it would
involve the man's right to choose
whether or not he wants to be a part of
her family well i i just see it as
because when i was covering the the
pro-abortion protest outside uh alito's
home earlier this week i was calling
them that they were they were
pro-abortion protesters are at this
house and people are some people were
just saying oh you're being so
disingenuous by calling them
pro-abortion they're pro-choice and it's
the choice to do what yeah it's like
when the people are like the civil war
wasn't about slavery
right states rights to what is that no
exactly and so i mean i just view it as
that's that's what they're advocating i
mean that's the whole they're not
but let's let's
make one point real quick no this whole
okay all right well then no no no no no
no
this whole point you just made here
where they would claim it was
disingenuous for you to call them
pro-abortion instead of pro-choice that
logic can be extended to literally any
political position i'm not pro-gun i'm
just pro for a person choosing to have a
gun you have to call gun rights
advocates pro-choice now you can't call
us bro gun you have to call it
pro-choice i'm pro-choice on guns yeah
exactly you have a right to choose and i
have no problem saying i'm pro-gun
exactly why won't they say pro-abortion
because they know it's evil we had in uh
the tim cass newsroom
some articles that were like saying
pro-life pro-abortion anti-abortion
pro-choice anti-choice whatever um i
don't know if we've ever said
anti-choice but i was just like i saw i
saw a few articles and i thought to
myself we shouldn't use pro-life or
pro-choice those are political terms we
should we should we should just refer to
the groups and what they advocate for in
that time
so when the left goes out like we are
proud choice and i'm like no you're
pro-abortion because i could name a
million circumstances where you don't
have you don't care about a person's
right to choose anything right vaccine
mandates is very obvious and they say
yeah well pro-lifers aren't pro-life
because they're for the death penalty
and i'm like yeah we're going to call
them anti-abortion if you're at a
protest and you're like abortion should
not be allowed you are an anti-abortion
protester saying pro-life is a political
term and i'm not gonna make an argument
about what life means or what choice
means if you go out you say we want
abortion you're pro-abortion if you say
no abortion you're anti-abortion we're
done that's it yeah well it's funny
because they will usually try to use
terms like anti-abortion as a smear as
if it's something to be ashamed of that
i'm against abortion oh no also they'll
also use terms like probers like you're
not pro-life you're just pro-birth i'm
like yes you maniac what is wrong with
being pro-birth like because they don't
know what your argument is yeah and so
they say like i just when i see all
these memes on facebook i'm like ah it's
so frustrating because they've never
talked to a conservative about this
and then so i can see this and i can
i'll say something like
they'll say something ridiculous like
it's about power and old white men and
then i'll say something like actually
the major the majority of uh pro-life
people tend to be women females and it's
actually really simple because there's
slightly more women in this country you
can call whatever you want and then
they'll say you're a right-winger and
i'm like i'm just trying to like tell
you what they're saying because you're
not talking to them yeah but they don't
know when it comes to pro-choice i think
the reason that we're going to use
because some people will say i don't
want an abortion i'm not going to get
one but i don't think the government has
a right to stop other people from
deciding that stuff does that can't make
what if you have a five-year-old and you
and you lose your job and you can't
afford it anymore
are you pro-choice
well it depends on how you feel should
the government be involved in whether or
not you strangle your kid to death
because you're broke and can't afford
the kid
what if you have a nine month old baby
like it's been out of the room for a
gestation for nine months nine months in
fresh air and then one day you're like i
have no money
should you have a right to choose oh i
think that when you say pro-life it's
implicit that it's invol only when
you're talking about the abortion
conversation as well that's why i said
we won't use either in the context of
these protests timcast.com won't say a
pro-life protester or pro-choice we'll
say anti-abortion or pro-abortion
someone who shows up and says i'm
pro-life it's like it's a political term
but and there are many areas of life you
are not saying all life is sacred i
would say like if i i'm pro-choice and i
but i don't think the government should
get involved but i'd be happier if no
one ever got an abortion that i'm not
pro-abortion i think abortion's horrific
you're not pro-choice
well i don't want the government to be
like you can't decide what to do with
your body so can i ask you so if you're
someone who is in favor of the second
amendment and strong gun rights but you
didn't personally own the gun would we
not still call you pro-gun
we wouldn't just say well he's pro
choice he's pro allowing to choose you
know allow someone to choose whether
they're going to own a gun we don't do
this yeah like we don't do this with any
other political conversation
choice yeah well it's a second tier
conversation it's a second tier label
already you want to know topic is
already there you want to know why they
call themselves pro-choice because it
sounds better than pro-abortion
absolutely yeah because abortion is like
the actual procedures and also a lot of
people don't want to get abortions that
feel like the government shouldn't be
involved in this pro-life sounds better
than anti-abortion granted pro-choice in
my opinion sounds worse
like pro-abortion sounds worse than than
anti-abortion sounds but these are
political terms meant to garner support
i i look at it this way what does it
mean to be pro-life in a general sense i
do not believe it encompasses all life
i certainly think there's an argument
from conservatives about some people
through due process forfeiting their
right to life the death penalty i can
understand that but i don't think that
is part of the conversation so i don't
like the term pro-life it's a broad
generalization life's an abuse
anti-abortion is fine you oppose
abortion shamus are you anti-abortion
yeah i am and i'm like i'm fine with
anti-abortion as a label but i still
think pro-life is consistent because my
desire to be anti-abortion it comes from
an understanding that all human life is
precious and sacred so i'm just very
proud of human life and so my issue is
the the conversation around the death
penalty is not a part of the pro or
anti-abortion argument so if there are
protesters outside saying abortion
should be banned i'm not going to be
like interesting the signs they're
holding up send a strong message about
the death penalty because it doesn't you
don't know their position on the death
penalty based on them saying they're
they're opposing abortion that's why i'm
like we
if if there was a protest for against
the death penalty we'd say pro and
anti-death penalty well yeah exactly so
the pro-life only is in the reference of
abortion is what that means and
pro-choice is only in the reference of
abortion nobody says
no no leftist goes to an anti-death
penalty protest holding up pro-life
science right if you were to talk about
it
if if that language not art was not
already being used in the abortion
debate they probably would well yeah
maybe in the context that i've seen is
that because i've been covering the
southern border crisis a lot especially
since the last time i was on here um no
no one who who
you know advocates for what the bible
administration is doing which is
essentially opening up the southern
border to illegal immigration they're
not going to say they're pro-open
borders they're going to say they're
pro-immigrant they're you know they're
pro asylum seekers even though you know
when you break that down into well who's
who's crossing and how are they crossing
what are they doing after they illegally
cross an international border it gets
into these word games i will say though
i am pro breakfast
burrito yeah me too i think we can all
agree on that how many
how many uh what percentage of pro pro
life individuals conservatives do you
think would take issue with being told
they were anti-abortion and having that
label on them that's a good question i
don't think anyone who's against
abortion would be upset being called
anti-abortion and i can't be wrong i
don't know how can i speak for everyone
i can tell you outright that when i say
pro-abortion they lose their minds
mm-hmm they say no way or not well
that's
that's exactly what i've been
experiencing
these past few weeks on you know random
random twitter this is what david pakman
tweeted and says where are the
pro-abortion people
and then you know hassan made a joke and
he was like me i'm trying to do this and
then i screen grabbed it and he accused
me of not understanding it was a joke
and i was like i thought it was funny
actually like because other people took
it seriously yeah it wasn't music i just
screen grabbed it and then he accused me
of taking it seriously but
david's own followers took it seriously
but the point is
when they say who's who are these
pro-abortion people they all go not
we're not pro-abortion we're just saying
it should be allowed it's like i i'm not
i'm not for drugs i'm just saying
everyone should be allowed to have well
but part of what was
part of what was particularly hilarious
about that thread that with uh pakman
was it wasn't just
um you know hassan responding to it
there were many many people in the
replies getting a lot of likes saying
things like well of course i'm
pro-abortion just like i'm pro any other
medical procedure what's wrong with
abortion just completely destroying his
argument or the people saying there are
too many people and the world's dying
why are you having kids anyway all right
settle down bill gates yeah yeah yeah
wow he got covered
let's talk about nancy pelosi
nancy you reap what you sow
pro-abortion activist pro sets up
protest outside of speaker nancy
pelosi's san francisco mansion
now it wasn't the biggest crowd ever it
was like seven people i guess
so it's small right but but
understand that's a a very serious
security issue it is it really really is
especially like you know i think it's
wrong to do i don't think people should
be going to the homes of anybody it's
like we got to have areas that are
sacred but you know what nancy she
praised the protesters who were going
out to the homes of the supreme court
justices
chuck schumer same thing
the president encouraged it i love the
hill ramp this piece that says joe biden
encourages illegal protests in front of
you know justice's homes or whatever
and i'm just like yo
the rule of law has broken down but at
the very least you see something like
this you report you so
nancy pelosi probably doesn't care
though because you
you taxpayer are paying her security
bills so she can advocate for it all day
and night people will then show up and
she'll be like see i don't care and then
the money we spend funds the security to
keep her safe when people show up at her
house
i don't understand why these people are
uh at her house right now did she say
something that pissed them off oh i
think they're they're she's supporting
henry cuellar in uh the district that
represents laredo texas on the right on
the border he is he's one of like the
last like pro-life dems and i'm sorry
anti-abortion pro-life them whatever um
and so
there's been on the progressive side of
things there's been a lot of people
who've been upset at police saying why
are you supporting henry cuellar when
you're trying to
you know talk about
preventing roe v away from being
overturned so i i i didn't see this
until until just now but i'm going to
assume that's part of the reason why i i
i think it might actually just be that
there is no logical argument there is
just power if it's good for the
revolution it's good if it's bad for the
revolution it's bad and nancy pelosi is
in a seat of power and they would prefer
one of their
you know political tribesmen or whatever
to be in that seat of poverty
i mean i was just covering a a a
pro-abortion protest in los angeles and
this was very far far left people not
just mainstream democrats and and they
were pissed that democrats uh they they
don't view them as
as technically on their side than you
know the far left this was the party for
socialism and liberation that was like
the group that organized it
so i mean we see the you know the
fringes right the fringes don't view the
main the mainstream political parties as
as being different they view them as one
of the same and
uh gonna plug the book here really quick
and i talk about that in in the book
when it comes to antifa and some of the
chazz uh occupiers during that time but
to bring it back i think that's why
again i don't know who who was there and
who organized that but that could be
just another thing too where they just
view the pelosi being part of the
political establishment and political
assessment's all one in the same i think
there is going to be
a reckoning of all reckonings in this
country we have this story from uh
post-millennial that goes along with
this glenn younkin slammed for
lackluster response to protest outside
scotus justice's home
yeah glenn younkin said we're going to
do a security perimeter and everyone's
like yo 18 usc blah blah blah whatever
says you can't demonstrate to try and
influence a court or a judge or whatever
and they're doing it and they get away
with it and the media comes out and acts
like egad the far right has called for
the arrest of people who've broken the
law
and they they they they got will
chamberlain jack bosovic me and a few
other people in this daily beast fake
news article where i'm just like was it
patricio did you write that maybe i
don't know there was a dude from occupy
who tweeted at me and he was like 10
years ago you would have defended this
peaceful protest and i was like
10 years ago i filmed people deflating
police tires and said if you do
something in public you get seen doing
it like you take responsibility for your
actions and that non-violent civil
disobedience results in you getting
arrested i've always maintained that
position it's like it's so weird the far
left has gone so far left they're like
tim you would have agreed with our more
extreme position what happened and i'm
like no no you don't understand my
position hasn't changed you changed you
used to think we agreed because we did
and then you left and said why don't you
agree with me anymore
i think these people should be arrested
i think the police should walk up take
their hands very slowly put them in
cuffs bring them into the in the police
van or whatever take them to the station
they get charged with their little
misdemeanor you know protest charge the
judge says don't let me catch you there
again they get a court supervision
ruling which means basically nothing it
means don't go back and they made their
point they got press but they got
arrested and then if they go back and
get arrested again they get a harder
sentence yeah but it's usually like a
weekend
well okay and so the the idea is there
has to be limitations
we have to say for these reasons we have
made something illegal but just because
something is law doesn't mean it's right
we talked about that with murder many
countries with despots were like the law
allows us to do it it's wrong there are
many laws that i think are wrong so what
do you do non-violent civil disobedience
you should get a slap on the wrist i
mean obviously depending on the severity
but i mean like if someone's going to
pick it protest parade or otherwise they
shouldn't do it at someone's house i
think that's unethical and that's
immoral but if they do it is also at a
judge's house illegal and we have to
have the police say this is codified law
i don't think these people's lives
should be over i don't think they should
get a year in jail that's the maximum i
think the judge should be alive court
supervision let me not see you here
again tim enforcing the law is
insurrection i'm sorry oh yeah it's bad
for our democracy
i found a good way to change uh unjust
law it's great the united states is
awesome because of 50 states 50
different legal systems kind of so you
if it's legal in one state and illegal
in the neighboring state you do it in
the legal state and you communicate with
people where it's illegal in the illegal
state and you change their minds while
you're doing it where it's legal and
then you have the opportunity to kind of
change the law that way without actually
having to go disobey directly this is
why i think overturning roe v wade is
actually very important
it allows for this
decentralized testing pool of law
the 50 states it's quite brilliant each
state has jurisdiction over their state
to set laws
to a certain degree i respect supreme
court precedent on protecting
constitutional rights i think they i say
to a certain degree because i think they
get things wrong sometimes i think the
nfa should never have been allowed the
supreme court should have struck all
that down but even alito was like there
are limitations no i'm sorry not a leto
scalia
so
the idea is
taxes has laws
new york has different laws
eventually we can actually look at the
data and be like which place is better
granted there's different terrain
there's different resources but allowing
this allowing people to decide for
themselves in their own areas i think
actually would help preserve the union
would help make people live together
better because you know if you're like i
don't want to live in texas these laws
i'm going to move somewhere else well
new york's awaiting they're welcome
they're going to welcome you with open
ups chicago says abortion oasis if you
don't like what texas or oklahoma or
whatever is doing you can go right to
illinois and then you get carjacks
perhaps as you're driving hold on
everywhere outside of chicago is red so
you can go to a you know red area and
you're probably going to be fine
less population that's i do think there
are um
there there are
important distinctions in what should be
federally protected across the board
like um nondiscrimination on the basis
of race sex national origin etc the 1964
civil rights act i think that makes
sense but here's my favorite point in
all of this
at these protests there is no equality
under the law i see this as a clear
violation of the 14th amendment and that
these people are not being arrested
equality under the law means that if you
break the law you are held equal same as
everybody else right
these people are arguing that the 14th
amendment equality under the law
guarantees a woman's right to abortion
due to her right to privacy and medical
choices
at the same time they're actively
defending that they don't get criminally
charged under existing statute which is
not equality under the law so don't come
to me and say the 14th amendment
guarantees shut up until you say arrest
me because i did break the law i don't
believe you're serious and you're only
trying to seize power and you're a liar
you're liars well i mean look they're
used to being above the law i know you
know a lot about this given the book
that you have written i'm curious if uh
you see any of this as being a fallout
from 2020 or no no i mean absolutely and
and not not to get too headed but i mean
the reason why there's so much concern
about
more riots or some level of unrest if if
roe v wade is actually overturned is
because when you look at
how how much people were able to get
away with on such a large scale in 2020
in terms of looting in terms of
attacking police officers in terms of
just general lawlessness i mean they
were able to get away with a lot and
even the ones that were arrested i mean
portland's like the prime example but it
happened in other places like new york
city and in chicago and
so on and so forth and so that's why
you know why wouldn't they run the same
playbook because not only are they gonna
get favorable media coverage like they
already have and not only they're gonna
get the blessing of democrats like like
right now
uh they're they're gonna be there's a
very good chance of not facing any
consequences if they do anything very
very severe
so i mean we
part of the reason for the book is to to
explain how we got here as a country and
and we are
we are we've lost the plot on just so
many things and we are in such a worse
position to be able to confront not even
just like issues of racism or
or abortion but it's just
because
people saw violence worked to to a
degree it's okay why not just con
continue that when we don't get what we
want yeah so what was the most shocking
part about the 2020 riots to you as
someone who's done extensive research on
this
so
it was the main my main takeaway was
just how fragile society is
and it's pretty fragile i mean and when
we look at i mean 2020 was also just
such a unique year right because we had
the emergency covid we didn't know too
much about it and then all this panic
around it and then we also had a very
heated 20 election presidential election
and then there was a spark with george
floyd
so when when you get these conditions
just right and and that's why since the
derek joven trial there hasn't been
really anything
crazy happening because there have been
instances where i thought oh a police
action that's controversial maybe i
should go to that city and then nothing
happens but because there needs to be
more build up kind of you know we the
country has gone through these cycles of
of of build up and then raged with you
know the star the summer rights in 68 67
uh then we look at ferguson and then and
then now and then with minneapolis in
2020 2021
so even if
you know there's no mass violence posts
overturning roe v wade i i would say
that it's kind of more like a jenga
block that's put into the build-up to
that to where then maybe 2024 and that
presidential election and what will the
country look like then are we going to
be in severe economic
you know depression and downturn and
then you know when you when you put
people in these in these extreme
positions
uh through no fault of their own
especially
they're gonna do
crazy things and and you know a lot you
know doing these lockdowns i think
definitely
contributed to 2020 because what was
happening around just the timing of
everything it was it was late may
especially in a place like minneapolis
it was warming up people were tired of
staying home people lost their jobs
because of lockdowns and so they it was
just
it was just a perfect uh tinderbox
essentially that all it needed was
something like a george floyd to happen
so
then leading to that i mean with
minneapolis
being there on the ground shortly after
after that it was it was crazy just how
the kind of the basic tenets of what we
know to be a civilized society just
wasn't there in terms of uh
you know for example i was so used to
protests not a flat not affecting
a couple blocks around where the event
was happening but i quickly realized
that there was no stores open
the the stores that were nearby they
were all being looted and so i ran out
of water because i was out there all day
and so i had to grab water from from the
target that was looted because they were
they were putting they were putting um
all the stuff that hadn't been loaded
into this giant uh pile
so that people could just grab whatever
they wanted so i just took what i needed
and then moved on but it was just it was
weird there's no public transportation
there was no uber there was a lift
clearly there's no cops i mean it was
just it was such a weird time and so
that really
was what was worrying going into 2021
thinking well is this kind of like the
new normal now in terms of just how the
immediate reaction to something that is
viewed as unjustified is then just
massive violence and lawlessness what
frustrates me with most stuff is like i
just want to know what the rules are
and if the rules were applied evenly
then i'd be like play ball you know what
i mean like let's have those arguments
but instead it's like they they
you ever play monopoly with someone who
just gets angrier and angrier yeah a
better example is have you ever played
pokemon the card game i know many people
in our audience probably did when they
were kids and you probably had somebody
where it's like
yo my my uh you know gyarados does 50
damage to your dude and i win and start
getting angry because they're losing so
they just flip the table yo i watched
watch i once saw a kid pick up his razor
scooter and smack the other kid during
uh during a competition or contest or
whatever in the tournament so we were at
a game shop and there it was a pokemon
tournament or whatever so back when i
was like 14 and some kid picked up his
scooter and just whacked the other kid
with it
that's what this feels like to me we are
having a political contest
and have you ever seen an argument where
someone's very calm and they're like i
think x y and z and the other person is
getting angrier and angrier that's what
it is and there's no moderator normally
the moderator should step in and be like
yo yo yo yo tone it down turn it down
you're yelling you know let's keep it
civil
in this political debate that has
reached the streets one side is getting
angrier and angrier and they're smashing
windows and starting fires and beating
people
because they're losing the argument
the moderator's the national guard
that's why i was asked at the beginning
of the show ask you again do you think
that they should have sent in the
national guard day two of these
minnesota riots yeah absolutely and and
part of the problem and because when we
when you look at los angeles 92 right
right after right after rodney king and
the trial that resulted it did take a
long time
for the national guard and even active
duty forces in the marine corps was also
deployed during that time
uh
it took a while for them to get there
and then that that's part of the reason
why the rides were so destructive as
they were and it just seems like we're
in this constant cycle where
uh riot
response is updated and then because
it's sometimes decades until the next
one those those those policies and the
people in charge they leave and they
change and so things are outdated and
and probably another good example of
that was kenosha because part of the
part everyone was asking why did it take
so long for the national guard to to get
there and the sheriff i remember he said
during a press conference they they
didn't
uh
they didn't follow the proper procedure
to officially request the national guard
he said that we got our wires crossed
how many and the same thing happened in
minneapolis they didn't the the mayor
jacob fry heat fray whatever
he
they thought they put in the official
request to do it you know the proper way
to do it and they didn't just because it
no one does this how many people
got arrested for rioting in kenosha
oh i don't know that number well not
enough clearly what were there i i mean
people people got arrested a few a few
did i mean after the fact uh but in
terms of i mean
during
during the riots i didn't see besides
kyle well that's the point yeah no the
one the one arrest i do know about was
kyle rittenhouse the one the guy who was
trying to protect the neighborhood who
ran away who rendered aid to the to the
to even the protesters and writers
themselves who fled for his life
defended himself
and then tried turning himself in turned
himself in and went through the ringer
on all this and i'm like what about the
dude who bashed the old man in the head
with the rock remember that yeah i i i
interviewed that man for the book was he
arrested uh no no no the old man i
interviewed the old man was that was it
was the guy who bashed him we don't know
i don't know
it's fascinating you see you said the
national guard's the moderator no
they're not the moderator the national
guard is the bad parent where one one
child is sitting there playing with his
video game and the other kid comes over
and punches him and takes it and the
parents run over go whoa whoa stop
fighting stop fighting or the bad
teacher who sees a kid gets get tripped
in the hall and then says zero tolerance
you're both getting detention it's like
dude one side is committing violent acts
and destruction
and the other side is like please stop
this and the national guard comes in or
the police come and say everybody calm
down everybody it's like the people who
came down there with kyle rittenhouse
were like we're going to protect these
buildings and render aid to the riders
themselves hope everyone's safe and then
what happens kyle is the one after
getting attacked who ends up going to
jail for two months and having his life
destroyed fortunately at this point it
was not he's recovered from it because
justice was served but it's just it is
vomitous to hear these stories over and
over again that's why i tell you when
when they announced we were in austin
when they announced the the written
house verdict
people were crying
good people women were crying i don't
think i saw any dudes crying but i did
see women crying i made a cartoon about
that about people crying over written
house oh that's right you're the cartoon
guys i think you guys will will
appreciate that one but
with the whole situation joy and relief
oh okay well no there were there were
there were women well it was a surprise
to be honest that were like crying tears
of joy and relief that this kid was not
going to be sent away for life for
protecting his his home in his and where
where he lived like and the left right
every lie gone across state lines he
didn't really live there his mom dropped
him off that that didn't happen all
these lies all the lies all of the lies
and
this is the guy and i watched a video
where an old man was bashed over the
head with a rock why wasn't that dude
who bashed the old man run through the
ringer why wasn't he the one standing
trial there is no moderator it wasn't
even a story well
the official response in kenosha was
because i mean the the the governor tony
evers he only called up 150 national
guardsmen that was the initial response
and that was not nearly enough to
actually secure
a town granted kenosha's not that big
compared to like minneapolis but when
but when the the city leaders of the
state leaders they they did abdicate
their responsibility because again they
didn't want to in my opinion they didn't
want to seem like they were cracking
down on racial justice protesters and
then that leads a power vacuum to where
then people like kylo ren house you know
with good intentions they're like hey
we're not going to let people just
destroy this town anymore and we're
going to we're going to prevent you and
we're going to stop you so you just
continue moving on doing what you do and
then
yeah something like raquel written how
situation is created and and yeah it was
i mean i was there for the second half
and i was there covering the trial
and
it was it was just it was just it was
just so
weird seeing how when being at the trial
and seeing the facts laid out because
you know i didn't know every single
aspect of it i didn't you know like i
said we saw the second half of it
but the the only good thing about the
trial is that it did lay everything out
you know unfortunately he did suffer a
lot to get to that point but there's
nobody who's going in there with an open
mind can then come away and say okay
yeah he definitely is a white
supremacist terrorist murderer that just
wanted to mass shoot everybody i mean if
that was the case he would have shot me
the daily beast
is now rated as fake news by news guard
because they have refused to correct all
of the fake news they wrote about kyle
rittenhouse that's the that's the
principal reason why they've been
knocked down i love it because whenever
these daily beast writers who just do
hit pieces on conservatives or
libertarians i just screen grab the news
guard thing and i'm like let me send
that to them you know like here you go
you're fake news you are fake news and
it's not it's not even just it's not
even just them but i mean with
with the whole cano i mean not to harp
on kenosha it's too much but the the one
of the egregious examples of of the
mainstream media just misportraying what
was actually happening i mean cnn
multiple times
stated that jacob blake as a fact wasn't
was unarmed i mean they didn't they
didn't say appeared to didn't say it
looked like it i mean it was hard to
tell with the initial video didn't he
rape some woman uh that well so the the
two kids that were in the back seat of
the car and i mean this is what led to
the whole thing was that the woman that
he took the kids from that was who he
sexually assaulted and so that's why she
she had a protective order against them
and that's why the police were called in
so when the police were on their way
they were they said oh by the way he
he has this is his history and so he's
re-victimizing this woman and trying to
take her kids and then and and he's
armed with a knife and the taser
apparently didn't work and so i mean it
the video alone like when i first saw
the video i thought okay yeah this looks
bad but this this this doesn't just
happen a cop is not going to just plug
away at this guy in the back but the
whole reason why he did is because he
was armed with a knife and he was about
to go into this car with two kids in the
back and take him away and so then the
officer had to think well then if
they're gonna chase after them that puts
the two kids lives at risk who's who's
this guy do you guys know who this is
saints i don't know football quarterback
no who is he i don't know people and the
people in the chat
player he's a guy more like the ants
he's holding the football and he's got
jacob blake on his helmet yeah uh what
he was convicted of assault actually
assaulting that one wasn't he
uh yeah i think so yeah and so she had a
protective order or protect a protective
order i don't know if he was convicted
but there was a protective order because
she made that yeah because she yeah she
had that that case against him and so
and and it's not not even just not even
just not even just that i remember i
think the wnba also did something for
drew brees is that what they're saying
drew brees yeah it's saints quarterback
imagine imagine being like a celebrity
and putting like dahmer on your hat or
helmet kamala harris visited him in the
hospital yeah and and and this and he
said oh they're a good fan
they're a good family sorry that's what
she said to him too tim what the laugh
from wikipedia says blake had a warrant
for his arrest from july based on
charges third degree felony sexual
assault trespassing and disorderly
conduct domestic abuse he wasn't
convicted he had a warrant for his
arrest okay innocent until proven guilty
but just
imagining a scenario where you're like i
could respect innocent until proven
guilty
but the cops did not go there
thinking we're gonna we're gonna attack
this this unarmed guy they were like
this is a guy who's wanted for the
arrest on felony sexual assault charges
we need to bring him in and yes you do
need to bring that person in you can be
innocent until proven guilty and the
state has a right to stop you and those
charges to be levied against you he
resisted he grabbed a knife at the very
least a guy holding a knife who was
wanted for sexual assault and they're
like i'm going to put his name on my
helmet
well and
that was to go back to my initial point
with with the media initially saying as
a fact not even being speculative saying
he was unarmed i mean do you do you not
think that didn't incite people to come
from madison to come from chicago there
was guys that came from minneapolis
to to to
take advantage of what was going on i
mean and that's why
it's so frustrating having been there i
mean that's i mean that was what the
title of my book right i mean because
cnn it's like because i met oh i've met
omar jimenez who was a reporter that was
msnbc no no
cnn yeah i i i think omar is a good
reporter and so on he was stating on the
ground that this was a riot that was
happening but it's like cnn has this
automatic reflexive response to just be
wrong on something and so the chiron
rider was a yeah fiery of mostly
peaceful i mean that doesn't even make
sense
we used to call this group the tourists
where when i would cover
protest or unrest these same people were
at every protest no matter what the
cause was
some of them actually bragged about
going to turkey and to china to advance
the protest in those countries and at
that point i'm just like you work for
the cia or something because like the
fact that you're in china organizing
protesters and turkey is i just have to
wonder but no i don't i don't genuinely
think or accuse them of being
intelligence or anything i think they're
revolutionaries and i think they just
want to destroy
so you'd be in new york and someone
would be like trayvon martin and sure
enough there this group is my favorite
moment
was the trayvon martin protest when some
of the tourists arrived
knew how to manipulate a protest march
got in front of it and then tricked the
march into going to wall street to
protest at the bull and the actual
organizers were like throwing their arms
in the air like why are we here we're
supposed to go to the police station but
instead like there's people jumping on
the ball and stuff and i'm like the
tourists took over
they these are they're like they're
extremist revolutionaries
this is what you need to understand
these people cannot engage in violence
unless they have a shroud of regular
people to protect them
they would love to go out with 10 people
and smash windows they would get caught
what they need is a shock moment that
will garner 200 people to come out
they then tell everybody show up in
solidarity wear all black so they can
and then they can destroy things smash
things burn things etc and it's
impossible for the state to figure out
who did it
well and and one of my
one of the things that is also
frustrating about having covered all
these riots is that there are some
people on the left who like to point to
right-wing infiltrators i mean they in
minneapolis there's umbrella man that
they accuse of being being an
infiltrator uh they say that this
boogaloo boy was the one that set the
third pre-song to him fire and so let's
just say for the sake of argument to
borrow from ben shapiro okay for the
sake of argument king there we go
let's just say yeah it was all
right-wing infiltrators that set the
third pre-song on fire and as someone
who was there i can tell you that none
of the actual black lives matter
protesters rioters had any issue of who
said who set the building on fire i mean
they that there was a whole reason why
they were there because they wanted to
actually set it on fire with the
officers still inside they were all
celebrating they were all happy that
this was on fire so even if
that you know this was the work of
extreme right wing trying to make the
movement look bad i can tell i can tell
you being outside there that everyone
was so happy and they wanted to continue
to the other precinct which was the
closest one was the fifth precinct and
they thankfully weren't successful in
destroying that but it's just it's but
they can't it's like they can't accept
the rhetoric that they that they say i
mean all the time you hear revolution
you hear we gotta do direct action but
as soon as there is direct action and on
a pretty big scale they want to back up
and say well actually it wasn't us it
was people were trying to make us look
better it's like no you you're
practicing what you're preaching and
also just the fact that other people
were were charged with setting the uh
third person up remember that guy who
stole the body armor and like the gun or
something
like from the burning building he stole
body armor i remember something like
that yeah one guy i do remember one guy
who went into the before they got sent
on fire came out with like a right
helmet and and he held it up in the air
and everyone was cheering i think about
some people are dumb senator in the
national guard like like i think that
trump was afraid because he was the
president i think this was his kenosha
was afraid that uh
we'd have another may 4th kent state
shooting on our hand where the national
guard fired into a crowd of college
students killed four people but firstly
it wasn't like a peaceful protest like
at kent state that was relatively
peaceful from what i know it was a
violent riot uh even at that stage they
were i mean they were rioting day one i
believe i i think
that probably a bunch of republicans
said no no don't stop the writing the
writing is good the rioting will get you
to win elections
that's that's i mean i don't know that's
treason treason involves another country
no it's not crazy sedition what would
you call that i'm willing to bet there
were i don't know if they said this to
trump but i'm willing to bet that they
were republican strategists who are like
the more riots they are the better our
chances come the end of the year
well that's obviously not the case we've
seen the proof is with the past we see
that that is not the case if you let
riots burn everything dissolves into no
it no no it
black lives matter after george floyd
had its highest approval rating ever in
aggregate at 51
and then it dropped to nine percent uh
uh well i'm getting those numbers wrong
it was like 26 net approval and dropped
to like nine percent net approval there
because he didn't he didn't stop the
rides he didn't get involved because the
riots
as soon as they started rioting public
support collapsed i think it went from
like 51 percent to like 40 percent and
that well part of the problem is that it
just it just continued happening i mean
when when everything first started i
initially thought that okay i'll cover
minneapolis and i'll go home and that'll
be it but then things things kept
happening no matter how thin of an
excuse that
that they hit that they had they were
they were they were going to write
because that was then this is what i was
saying before the automatic response and
what really hit me was when i was
covering a riot in wauwatosa wisconsin
which is probably about like an hour and
a half northwest of of kenosha where it
was a black officer who shot a black
teenager who was armed with a gun had
shot the gun previously he was pointing
the gun at the responding officers and
uh but this was all free george floyd
and pre covet and so that's why no one
knew about this and so since the
milwaukee district attorney was making
decision whether or not to criminally
charge uh the officer in a post-george
florida world that's why there was riots
in the first place but the thing is is
just that
being in that town i mean it really
looked like my hometown of wheaton i
mean
there were there it was a black lives
matter caravan from madison that made
their way to wauwatosa and as soon as
they hit the city of limits they started
destroying everything inside including
including take a look at this uh civics
polling on black lives matter from april
25th 2017 to may 10 22. we can see
net support
in uh just after george floyd was killed
hit 23 percent then the riding started
jacob blake got shot and what happened
polling dropped even more and went down
to eight nine percent continued to fall
derrick chauvin convicted support for
black lives matter went down again
verdict and they once again dropped down
to negative one percent net support so
you know what happens
every time now
we've had these three big moments jacob
blake's shot approval drops derek
chovin's convicted approval
drops
i think they're losing the narrative war
i think we've seen them we're seeing the
media companies falter i think more
people are starting to share shows like
this or other people are calling it out
i mean you look at someone like jimmy
dore and there really is an economically
bipartisan anti-establishment emergence
because jimmy's you know a lefty guy but
he calls up the machine he calls out the
the establishment the authoritarianism i
think regular people
if it's just fascinated after chauvin
was convicted support tanked massively
over the course of a couple months it
went from six percent net support down
to three two percent well because if you
remember right right before the the
verdict for derek shoving they had this
riots there was the riot in brooklyn
center and that was that that's the last
ride i covered it was april of of 2021
and so
again i mean yeah i mean now that was a
bad case where an officer is trying to
use a taser and accidentally choose a
guy
um but
again what what happened in that riot
was people who had nothing to do with
kim potter or dante wright
had to suffer the negative consequences
because people were people crazy and
going looting again i mean that
that it goes back to the two wrongs
don't make a right and that's why i'm
just against writing i want to pull up
this story from komo news
blm co-founder admits she held parties
at mansion with donor funds
don't forget folks when you give money
to black lives matter you are supporting
parties
parties at a mansion baby yeah come on
it's studio
take a look at this this polling
and right now as of today civic says 44
opposition 42 support you can see that
black lives matter has gone underwater
in the past month or so and it's only
getting worse
well there you go when more stories like
this come out when you find out nobody
knows who's in charge nobody knows where
the money was going they bought a big
mansion had a bunch of parties with your
money
you know to everybody who watches this
show to everybody who watches shows like
stephen crowders or people who are
calling out the lies from black lives
matter
their money's safe they didn't make
donations but these these regular people
who don't pay attention who are like i'm
gonna make a donation and then did and
all they did was fund a bunch of parties
and a bunch of nonsense and a bunch of
violence
like out there waking up to it now like
the minnesota freedom fund i mean again
right
she wasn't the the candidate then but
she i mean a senator kamala harris
shared this
uh bail fund because that was the that
was the current thing to do and you know
a lot of celebrities also you know
advocated for it and and donated to it
and and what happened what's even worse
in my opinion with that case is that
it's not even necessarily that i mean
the money was used to bail out actual
writers but in the months since then in
the year since then they've bailed out
some pretty egregious people who should
probably stay locked up and yet they get
released because they have all this
influx of cash all of a sudden thanks to
people like kamala harris and then uh
probably one of the
one case was that uh they they bailed
out this guy
um i forgot what the original charge was
for but he then went out and killed
somebody in a road rage incident shortly
shortly thereafter and the minnesota
freedom fund they put out a statement
saying
did say they confirmed that yes our
money was used to bail them out and then
they deleted it because they were i
think they were getting like too much
backlash so this is the problem with
with supporting the current thing and
the emotions running high is that
you're right people don't
think through what's actually happening
because if you actually knew how like
peaceful protesters work and when
they're actually arrested by police a
lot of times they just get written a
ticket
right they don't need they don't need to
get bailed out but because
someone wanted to do something and oh it
looks good and we're gonna virtue signal
and now people are dead i think it's uh
these leftist organizations know what
they're doing i remember during occupy
wall street there was the national
lawyers guild and they were helping
people that i had witnessed be
wrongfully arrested and the cops lied
and so i was like well that's cool
they're like lawyers and they observe to
make sure you know no bs from the cops
okay
then i saw them one day at a protest
where there was a like a bunch of right
wing people wanted to have a gap
have a protest or they wanted to have a
rally so the left showed up to oppose
that rally with violence the national
lawyers guild was on one side defending
antifa and i saw them and i was like how
come you guys are only observing one
side and they were like what and i'm
like shouldn't you be observing protests
in general why are you just with them
there was a group of black-clad people
wearing masks and sunglasses with
crowbars and two by fours and bats and
they were like
we're here to protect these protesters
and i'm like the guys over there with
shields are protesting i don't
understand why you're not protecting
them it's because these organizations
don't exist to protect the right to
protest they exist to serve the
revolution
yeah absolutely i mean i see those guys
out there all the time and they they
definitely
are and look i'm not for you know police
cracking down on people unjustly uh it's
just that in all the k and all the
rights that i personally covered it was
always rioters making the first move and
police responding and kind it's amazing
watching the right try to protest and
having no experience and no
organizational power and they think they
can go up to these cops and and and say
things
i just i it's funny watching these
videos and you'll see these
conservatives being like yo yo why are
you arresting him didn't do anything i
don't understand like what's going on
and it's like wow that's exactly what
the leftists say
like these these people thought they
could show up and that the cops were
going to treat them
like oh we these guys support us
right no then you see those videos where
the people are throwing the blue lives
matter flag in the dirt and stomping on
it in front of the cops because they
finally realize like dude those cops
don't care about you dude you go out
protest that's why the left has they've
been organizing for decades and they
have infrastructure and money behind
them so when they get arrested they all
get bailed out even if they're the most
crooked and evil people you've ever you
ever heard of and then you know maga
mima shows up waving a little flag and
now's in you know solitary yeah it's not
hard if you think about the allegory
like the french revolution i'm reading a
little bit about it like if they were
like and there were there were like
sympathizers to the revolutionaries in
the courts and that some of the french
revolutionaries were arrested and then
released you'd be reading about him that
is not even weird to me at all i can
totally see that happening as french
revolution they infiltrated the courts
they're working together so why is it so
hard to believe that that's happening
right now it's not it is hap it seems to
be happening right now i completely
agree with you i think people are in
denial about the fact that the left has
basically captured all of our most
authoritative institutions maybe not all
but some very very
uh some at the crux enough of them to
get away with rioting basically enough
of them to literally burn down buildings
and not face legal you know they set
fire to that church across from the
white house a historical church
and then the media and everyone's
aligned against trump over it they have
so this is how much institutional power
the left has and has had
they were able to intimidate a sitting
president of the united states into
going into the bunker of the white house
and it was not criticized by the media
they were considered to be peaceful
protesters they praised it
exactly
and they laughed at trump right they
laughed at this
and then they you know they accused the
right of being insurrectional and in
that and in that riot there were 60
secret service officers who were
injured injured
around around 60 park police officers
were also injured and yet that's not
viewed as an insurrection and that's why
with you know the whole january 6th
discussion i mean for me i view it as a
riot i mean and i was against that
because riots are not good
but it's just it's i i don't care what
anybody has to say about january 6 if
they then look at what happened at the
white house and they're you know and
because i mean that was also an attack
against one of the branches of
government i mean it's it's just so it's
just i know we get into the whole double
standard hypocrisy but
it's important to point that out because
when we're talking about the again the
history
of our country that you have to you have
to we have to remember where people
stood
when things were on other sides of the
of the debate yeah well i remember all
throughout the summer of 2020 when the
left was rioting i was seeing hot takes
from lefties who were saying things
along the lines of oh all the 2a
conservatives who said they wanted to
stand up to a tyrannical government are
awfully silent right now arguing
basically if anyone remembers that
conservatives should be laying down
their lives for a left-wing insurrection
then all of a sudden the left decides to
start pretending that they're against
insurrection labeling january 6th in
insurrection which is a bizarre thing
considering basically no one had weapons
we also know there was a
we're pretty sure based on the evidence
there was a lot of involvement from feds
there um and the narrative was not what
the media reported it as or has been
claiming it was but regardless now they
are once again in favor of insurrections
saying things like lori lightfoot for
example stating this is a call to arms
we have left-wing political leaders
saying we gotta fight we gotta fight um
what we need revolution yeah et cetera
she called she called for arms and
fights she says
we need to fight fight to victory that's
calling for weaponry yeah
alex jones got banned for basically the
same uh and chicago has plenty of them
yeah is that the truth the government
was set up so that we don't have to go
to another revolution if we do it right
although thomas jefferson made it very
plain that we may have to and that you
don't never do it but we shouldn't have
to we had a civil war
also well i want to mention this i think
what they were talking about was more a
revolt than a revolution so a revolution
is when you try to like completely
overturn the social order to build
something new whereas a revolt is when
you're trying to fight back against
something being are you like arguably
imposed upon so you think this is more
of a revolt i think this is more of a
revolution i don't know what's happening
i would argue that it's a leftist
revolution right they want to create a
new social order like they don't even
think that we should recognize the
differences between boys and girls
that's how bizarre and strange the
neutral orders seek to establish a
cultural revolution yeah a complete like
a complete a complete cultural and
political revolution yeah they just want
to overturn everything everything i mean
again the far left protesters in los
angeles they were calling for the
supreme court to be abolished which
which is always funny because okay if
that happens you do realize then
abortion goes to the same that's the
whole reason why we're in this position
in the first place they remember when
they were calling to abolish the senate
yeah i mean they're abolishing they're
abolishing left and right i mean i'm
open to change and revolution i don't
know a lot of a lot of anarchists and
libertarians probably like yeah
for a while i thought we should get rid
of the house of representatives because
they're getting bribed i'm like we need
it but but what i don't just want to get
rid of it you got to create something
better if you're going to change it you
got to you got to replace it like the
founding fathers didn't just fight and
kill a bunch of people and then be like
what do we do now like they had a plan
they had a bunch of paperwork they had
been debating for years and years
together and when it didn't work with
the articles of confederation they
replace it with something else and what
we have today i mean
it's it's really
i mean
especially with the antifa
people and
and those those guys they yes they are a
threat and like especially if they're
motivated in specific areas like the
pacific northwest but
they they also just hype themselves up
too much they they spray paint a cab on
the side of a wall and they jerk
themselves off on social media they say
look how awesome this is this is a
revolution you guys just spray painted a
wall right big wolf and then when it
gets below 40 degrees they they stay
home
a headless revolt this is from october
it's not even that long ago abolish the
senate
you know these people are just like
we've lost control of a body of power
abolish it yes
that's and again it's it's it's the
temper tantrum that that left us have if
we don't get what we want we want it to
go away or we'll take it or we'll
influence it through violence i wish
they thought of it more as a boat we're
all on that they don't like how fast
it's going so they want to
burn the boat as we're all on it and
like
it like no no no no we got to fix the
boat i wish that republicans felt that
way too yeah it'd be nice if you are on
a boat and there are people who are
destroying it with pickaxes you stop
them from doing it yeah yeah
i'm on a boat this also you know this um
this hot take that we should abolish the
senate this is so typical
often what happens is the the right will
either make like sort of a straw man
argument to poke fun at the left to
explain the most extreme possible
position and then the left will
literally meet them there and end up
unironically believing that thing so
i heard people saying after the
2016 election when the left was
complaining about the electoral college
well at that point why not abolish the
senate as well because if you think that
everything should be left up to a purely
popular vote then the whole idea of
representative government doesn't make
sense and that's what they want no i
know that's what they want and at first
left-wingers were saying
they were denying that that's ridiculous
that's not what we want and then of
course not that far down the line oh
that is what they want majoritarian rule
is not fun no
it's literally mob rule i don't mind
institutionalized a more direct republic
but i i do like the stop gaps that we
have so that mob can't make a crazy
decision tomorrow because the video went
viral
i think it's funny
spock the needs of the many outweigh the
needs of the few and i'm like that is
horrifyingly despotic that's like not a
good line dyspotic despot it's about the
same thing
it's millions of others it's this idea
that well you know these people need it
more than you so we're gonna take your
water it's very vulcan it's like very
logical i need i need water to live the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few justifies a person who has water
that he saved up for the winter it
justifies but these 10 people have no
water so they get yours because the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few and it's like well those many
didn't do any work all summer and now
are suffering because of it and i did
the right thing so i suffer because of
it or if your tailbone's you drink three
water three gallons of water a day what
was up with that call her back she said
she keeps her room is that real
87 degrees in the desert that's not real
maybe it's l.a los angeles probably got
super hot in there sweating all day
maybe she's a lizard person yeah that's
kind of what i was saying i think you
can drink i'm just basking like the sun
lamp and just like chill out
i always watch lizards do that i'm like
that must be like the best feeling
yeah if you're really still it doesn't
feel it's only when you start moving
that it gets really hot but if you're
really still cat's like in the sun too
you ever see it's funny like so we have
a window in my office and bocas will go
in there and lay in the sun and then as
the sun moves he like you'll look and
then he'll be laying there and sleeping
and i'll get up and like inch forward
and then go back i went to pet him with
wet hands and he like recoiled and i
thought a desert cat wants dry hands
sunlight anyway what happened we're
talking about talking about this
what is that
there's a good argument to be made about
like so when someone says something like
well the needs of the many way that
needs the fuel well i would argue that
the needs of the many include the need
for strong social structures that don't
allow you to just take things from
people because they happen to be in the
minority yeah outnumber them if you have
a group of 11 people and one of them
makes all the water the other 10 are
super lazy and they're beating their
kids and they're terrible the needs of
the many you gotta you look at the big
picture what is the needs of the species
do we really need those ten violent
abusive people
so what is the many at that point like
you might have to cut off the dead
weight you know what i'd love to see is
like a parody where spock is like the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few and then kirk is like yes but
what if the few are protecting what
they've built and then spock just goes
might makes right
then spock just goes shut up
the beautiful thing about spock was that
he was half human half vulcan so it was
an opportunity to have the logical
rhetoric and then
um captain kirk would give him like the
emotional human understanding like
basically the uh the reasoning or the
emotion
the needs of the many also can include
your mom so yeah do that
yeah when you say the needs of
themselves i want to mention that like
this this authoritarian idea the needs
of the many way that needs the few like
who gets to determine what the needs of
the many are oh the few small handful of
centralized people who you've decided to
get to determine what the deeds of the
money are okay you know it's gonna be
funny when uh taylor lorenz is like the
editor-in-chief of the new york times
oh goodness we should have her on the
show dude all of our addresses are going
to be at that point it's just the new
york times is going to become a phone
book
you all are laughing but it's going to
happen you think is that what she wants
to do i don't know but what's going to
happen is these millennials will
eventually take over these institutions
they work there so 10 years ago they
were interns and they were writing their
stupid garbage pieces about gamergate or
whatever 10 years later they're now the
star reporters in 10 years they're going
to be like you know i've been at the
times now for 25 years and as the
executive editor of the stories we're
going to run
they're going to be running these
institutions think about the the the uh
law clerk there's that viral meme where
the law clerk was like
it is
it is more dangerous that the courts
took away women's rights then the leak
happened and defied the sanctity of the
court
when they get into the the judicial
system and they are running these courts
they will have the same disdain for a
legal precedent and they're going to be
like i have the power and i can do what
i want so shut your mouth well i mean
and that that that because that's true
because i remember in you know growing
up in you know 20 the 2014 2016 that
whenever there was a freak out on a
college campus the the
from a social justice warrior what have
you
there was always that natural response
to say well wait till they get to the
real world they're going to it's going
to be a harsh reality and grow up and
that's not been the case and it took
over they took over it because
the older adults have to leave and they
you know grow old and they retire and
then who takes their place and we're
seeing that now with law schools but
especially i will say these people are
very non-functioning so when the boomers
age out and are no longer at the new
york times the new york times will go to
business yeah i've been waiting for it
to happen i'm surprised it's still
around but you you think well i think we
see an n plus one out of business well
for sure i mean and look at the ratings
you know what the key demo ratings were
for like anderson cooper on friday it
was like 90 000. that's crazy we get
like 500 000 so they're they're archaic
they're dying out
the boomers ran the show they knew how
the machine worked the millennials are
inheriting the system but don't know how
to make it work so what's going to
happen do you think these people are
going to know how to run a business
they're going to vote for government
subsidization of news they're going to
be the government should bail us out
because the news is so important and
then they're going to have allies in
government who are going to be like i
agree and it's going to be up to all of
us to be like no you're not getting our
money to fail to bail out these broken
systems at some point the media industry
in the country got it became no longer
the fourth what's it called the fourth
estate or the state yeah and it got like
co-opted by i don't know if it's the
it's the deep state yeah there's this
thing called the um i keep seeing this
it's like the uh oh what's it called the
uh council on foreign relations and all
their the web of how they have people
that are part of that that are also like
the heads of media organizations and
there's like this awesome graphic i
actually tweeted it out a couple months
ago um alex jones had it on the wall
like a big poster when i went to his
office and it's it just shows how all
these people are connected through this
council on foreign relations bilderberg
groups another one and then this i don't
remember the third trilateral commission
and the three of those businesses have
so much influence on like nbc abc cbs
disney
and and then they're putting out this
like coherent message that doesn't seem
like it's about about fact checking
anymore i i think if you look at the
media and how they're they've they've
lost the plot it shows you that
millennials can't make the machines work
so
how is it that these people keep falling
for the same fake news stories how is it
that these the press is like less
favorable than congress or whatever it's
because the millennials who are
inheriting it
don't know what people want to listen to
i'll mention that politico story i was
reading earlier where actually do i have
i don't know if i have that tweet pulled
up i don't where they were like
a democrat spoke to their colleagues
about how inflation is the is the big
issue for everyone and democrats were
shocked saying but i've not heard this
at all and it's it's like if if if you
did not know that people can't afford
rent
and you were shocked by that you do not
live in reality yeah that was uh katie
porter yeah the congress congresswoman
she said that oh i didn't know that
bacon cost this much now
by the way i love it when there's like a
joke about asking a rich person how much
a gallon of milk costs and they're like
i don't know 20 bucks because like i
have no idea i don't i have someone go
to the store for me and then they just
crumple the receipt but throw the
garbage exactly when they say our
democracy what they mean is you being
ruled by people who have absolutely no
understanding of what your actual
concerns are no no no
people who don't know that inflation's a
problem right now are the ones in charge
and if you don't want that to be the
case you don't when they say
this is a danger to our democracy
they are not including you
[Music]
imagine there are two countries in the
united states
there is the freedom faction and the
authoritarian faction
the authoritarians are talking to
themselves they say they are threatening
our democracy that doesn't include you
that does not include you they say this
is very dangerous to our democracy yes
we are a danger to their democracy
because we aren't included in it and we
demand our rights
we live in a constitutional republic
they live in a multicultural democracy
that's what's happening and both are
trying to seize power well i should say
one is trying to seize power from the
other side because it's always been a
constitutional republic here in the
united states
yeah no it's it's an interesting
question right because when you say one
side's trying to seize power it's not
exactly clear which side that is we know
the left has
been pushing forward their revolution
but when you consider the fact that they
have faced no legal consequences for the
rioting in the street
in other such illegal activities you you
wonder if they're not the ones you're in
control and it's the right which is
attempting to seize power back well and
that's why again that's why it's so
scary of where of where this country is
going in terms of i mean with again
this whole road versus weight issue
because yeah there i mean there's
protests tonight i don't know how big
they were uh because
uh outside of the conservative supreme
court justices homes again and are any
are they gonna be hunted down are they
gonna no exactly because because the the
media has been excusing it the white
house was excusing it and so if they
think okay we can continue pushing these
boundaries more and more once it is
actually overturned it's not
unreasonable to be concerned about okay
well then they're gonna take things to
to the next level i mean and we're
seeing it i mean we
no one's been caught yet uh but that's
why
uh pregnancy centers that have been have
been targeted yes and it's just they
they're the it's being ratcheted up and
they're justifying it because of what
happened in the 80s and 90s or whatever
and to me to me it's it's it to me it
feels like we're we're in this we're in
this car that's just careening towards
this this treat this massive tree trunk
and no one wants to hit the brakes have
you guys ever read i am legend yes i've
the actual short story
short story it's a pretty
well no it's part of a longer book which
is a collection of short stories so you
know the president robert neville yes
yeah which is which is that in the book
they are actually explicitly labeled as
vampires it's not as much of a zombie
movie as the film but basically there's
nobody left on earth except for this one
man and he pours vinegar on the steps of
his house and it's surrounded by
vampires every night who try to lure him
out and get them to join them the idea
is him to join them the idea don't spoil
the ending i'm going to spoil you how
dare you well that's that's the point no
it's a very good story the point is
when the vampires start emerging he goes
around killing them because they're evil
vampires who are turning people and
consuming blood
he loses eventually he's the last person
he realizes to the vampires he is the
legendary monster he is the creature
that lurks while they sleep who kills
them and jumps out of the light when
they when they can't see him and he's
the boogeyman to them
once once they took over he was the
hideous monster creature he was the
legend yeah yeah exactly
yeah and he that's his final ending
monologue is like well i am legend yeah
so my point is
eventually there will come a time when
either the constitutional republic is
consumed by the vampiric multicult
multicultural democracy or the other way
around
if the constitutional republic loses
there will come a point where you are in
your house surrounded by
multicultural democracy it will be
unrecognizable you have no
constitutional rights and you will be
the last remaining constitutionalist
holding on to your flimsy tattered piece
of paper that you bought at auction for
10 bucks because nobody wanted the
constitution anymore and then you'll be
like that's it
these ideas have died out
unless of course you preserve those
ideas by having a family having kids
building culture
challenging the establishment speaking
out and saying no to the vampires
yeah that's what you have to do do you
think you work with the vampires no no
no what about you trick them into
becoming your slaves they're vampires
you can cure them like in the movie that
was trying to do which was really dumb
the movie sucked no i like the movie
the movie just had no like the the point
of the story is the message about what
happens when you're the last human you
are the monster to them well sure but
the movie was just like
i got a dog and there's zombies i guess
yeah that's awesome uh whatever yeah it
wasn't yes
there was a shooting there was a there
was a dog and then the dog died and that
was sad julio we before we we're gonna
go super chats pretty soon but i was
wondering about your book because we
talked about the riots a little a bit
during the show was there anything in
there that you wanted to talk about that
was on your mind yeah buy it oh we're
good
where can people get it right now uh so
they can go to amazon i understand if
you don't want to go to amazon but it's
also on barnes and noble target a book
books a million thrift books uh and
that's as far as i know uh but
in all snares it's just
this this is supposed to be uh it's not
it's obviously not the end-all be-all
source of rise because i couldn't be
everywhere at once i wasn't i wasn't
everywhere unfortunately but it it to my
knowledge it's it's the and i don't want
to sound like i'm like
hyping myself up they're blowing myself
up too much but it's one of the first
really attempts
to jot everything down and accurately
retell everything that that happened in
in a written form because it is the
greatest piece of american literature
ever written yeah right yeah yeah oh i
guess i should get it patriots
fact-checked that and they said yes yeah
that's true yeah i saw i saw on patriot
warrior1776.info it said it was the
greatest book
yeah and so is it and the reason why
it's just so important is because again
that that there was just so much media
malpractice as it was happening and
especially in the aftermath of january
6th i mean
they the the people who are supposed to
be telling us our history and telling
things as they are they're saying no
january 6 is the only one that matters
and obviously i'm not that minimizing it
by any stretch of the imagination but
it's no there are also all your all
these other rights and one of the
greatest examples of that it was a new
york times piece shortly after january 6
and it was uh and it was literally about
that the premise was or republicans are
pointing to the blm riots and the line
was something to the effect of
republicans are using isolated instances
of property damage to what about january
6. and we're talking a minimum 2 billion
dollars worth of damage
multiple dozens of people were killed
over this time period and and
you're gonna
you're you're gonna minimize what
they're you're the the author of the
piece was doing the exact same thing
that he was accusing republicans of
doing and to me that's just that's just
egregious and and when we're talking
about the gaslighting and the playbook
that the media does is that and they do
this with every issue when it comes to
making
if it makes liberals look better
if they can make republicans look bad
with like the example of the florida
parental rights bill right i mean they
were calling it don't say gay and just
completely mischaracterizing it and but
that became that became canon in the
eyes of in minds of a lot of people
because they didn't actually read the
darn thing
but
they ran that same playbook because they
always do it but when it came to the
riots they still did that because in
their hubris and their arrogance they
thought well we're just going to do what
we've always done but it's a lot harder
to gaslight people and mislead people
when there's whole neighborhoods on fire
and there's mass lawlessness but they
still did it and that and that's the
point for me
that's just really frustrating let's go
to super chats if you have not already
smash that like button subscribe share
the show send in your super chat
questions and become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only segment coming up at 11 p.m i think
we'll be talking about the apocalypse
because there's a whole bunch of
apocalyptic stuff happening in terms of
droughts and the kind of collapse and
food shortages but there's some new
developments and we'll talk all about
that and it's not very family-friendly
but i think you'll laugh because we've
had some pretty crazy conversations
there but let's read these super chats
ehf says sheamus would make a beautiful
woman wrong that is absolutely
disgusting
you guys you're insulting the natural
order
hideous
all right
deprived dolphin says abortion industry
is a money laundering scheme it just
allows tax dollars to make their way to
democrat campaigns without anyone
questioning why roe v wade will result
in democrat collapse
really interesting
raymond g stanley jr says as a liberal
woman with two cats her umph i say
first of all if i i would have to have a
bunch of cats because i would just be a
hideous woman no one would it would just
be cats me and my cats that sounds good
to me n.s says tim your own website says
that arrest on protesters is iffy if ron
coleman says maybe then who's right you
or your news site it's called an opinion
it's called an opinion from ron coleman
an opinion from me and it's not about
being right about me saying i think they
should be arrested not that they will be
can be or that it would be uphold
upheld sorry um but yeah i mean look i
have my own opinions all of the segments
that go up on timecast.com from this
show and my show say opinion on them it
means it's what i think should be or
could be but not necessarily the like
the thing about opinions
people need to understand that something
can sound like a fact but it's an
opinion right if you if someone were to
say something like google is spying on
conservatives it sounds like a fact
statement like they're doing a thing but
it's actually legally an opinion
because you're saying like
i believe based on what i've seen the
challenge with fact statements is that
it can be an opinion if it's something
that's fairly nebulous or vague or hard
to definitively prove like there's a god
is that an opinion
uh i think that would be considered an
opinion statement
so but i don't think that's relevant any
legal context to be honest like there's
no circumstance in which the courts can
actually be like yes or no i think if
you're talking legally it's one thing
but it's complicated because a lot of
times
the lines get blurred so an opinion like
if you're saying something like ice
cream tastes the best that's i mean
that's an opinion but if you're talking
about whether or not god exists that is
something which is like objectively true
or false well the ice cream's the best
is a is a qualifying opinion there's a
qualifier in there but what you're
saying is you can have non opinions
without qualifier so you so there have
been instances where someone has said
something like
you know tv personality does x
and you're like wow they're saying they
did a thing and then they argue no it's
my opinion that they do this thing and
the courts are like right it's an
opinion
so can you prove google actually spies
on conservatives definitively with
evidence you could but what if you
stated they were
i'm not saying they are like google
spies on everybody i think oh how about
this google spies on people
google right now is spying on us
it's a fact statement right it's an
opinion statement actually
it's based on evidence and data that
leads me to a conclusion that is
you can't see it right i can say there's
a window in front of me and that's a
fact statement because there is i can
say you know i closed the window earlier
and you can say did he or did he not
google spying on people i would say is
objectively true but some will be like
yeah based on your interpretation of the
facts i'm like well they take our data
is that spying i don't think that's
spying spying would mean this no spying
would be that
did the person run was he running to the
store you said so and so ran yeah he was
moving very quickly i think that was a
brisk walk you see how it works
legally it's hard to have fact
statements but it sounds like you're
making a fact statement and technically
you are but if people don't agree on
what words mean then you get all sorts
of crazy
all right anyway i digress let's go back
to the super jets
zack kemp says why can't we talk about
allowing abortions but requiring the
doctors to do everything they can to
save the life of the baby and charge the
parents for medical procedures
i mean that's what i'm saying like if
they're saying this woman will die
unless this nine you know this baby at
nine months gestation is removed i'm
like okay remove it and then it lives i
guess right
yeah um why would they have to kill it
because that's the goal right the whole
goal is we need to kill this child
because we view them as a problem cost
if it's like we're going to remove the
baby there's a chance it'll live it's
going to cost you 400 000 or you can you
can abort it and it'll cost you 600
bucks
isaac luck says thanks tim i've been
wanting to order from biotrust but i've
been waiting for this offer i've
recently started keto and i've lost 16
pounds so far amazing glad to hear it
around november i cut out sugars we've
got the biotrust keto stuff and i've
dropped about 25 pounds that's a little
bit more than that right now it's like
it's like 27 or 28 no joke it's getting
crazy
i just cut out the sugars you know what
i found out
um michaela peterson made a really
really great point because she was doing
the all-meat thing right yeah she like
basically just eats lamb the lioness
diet i think she calls it she was saying
that it's not about just eating meat
it's about elimination it's about
getting everything out of your diet and
then slowly putting things back in until
you find out what was screwing with you
i found out bread messes me up really
bad
yeah it's not as much about what you eat
although it's about what you don't put
in your body fasting is a tool it's a
proactive it's an activity that you do
i i so i go for like a month with no
bread no no gluten
no bread
and i'm eating mostly like nut breads
and keto stuff and i feel fantastic we
go out to eat and i get breaded food
and always in the next day my whoop
recovery is cut in half
i feel groggy and cloudy and i'm like
man i think that's what it was and so
some have suggested it's fried food and
i'm like i have fried wings all the time
i get like you know wings and they're
fried and and rolled around in sauce and
all that i have no problem and there's
other fried stuff i've had that's not
gluten and i've like been fine with it
so i'm wondering if it is gluten i don't
know oh for sure i wouldn't be surprised
i i was eating some breaded food the
other night and i was like i'm starting
to get full and i just sat there it's
kind of meditating and i just heard like
celiac it just like came into my mind i
thought yeah that's what happens man
people dose on on wheat flour and then
they get celiac there's there's like
trendy diet stuff and i've never cared
so when i cut out the sugars
and then i was like i'll have a little
bit because i'm not going crazy with it
i would have some bread and then feel
sick but i didn't really think anything
but i think i've collected enough data
over the past you know since november so
about six months or so of looking at
what i've been eating and not eating and
tracking the woop data since i got it
and i'm like dude the days where i have
wheat grains my recovery drops it might
also also alcohol
and as a combination i mean that's you
know wheat based and alcohol my recovery
dropped so the whoop tells you like
you're recovering since i cut out bread
it's been 80 to 90 every day even when i
work out every day
had one beer the next day it was like 19
percent it was in the red and it was
like what did you do was it wheat beer
because regular beer i think it was a
bloomer oh it was a yingling oh i meant
is it made from wheat i don't know if
you knew your head
sometimes it's the stuff they spray the
wheat with like uh monsanto uses the
stuff called glyphosate which is uh a
chemical that they use it's like an um
an anti-fungal anti-insecticide or
insecticide but what they also do is
they use it as a desiccant meaning they
dry out the wheat with by spraying it
with this roundup this glyphosate before
and then they harvest it so if you're
not getting organic wheat you're you're
very likely getting glyphosate induced
right at harvest it's just that is
and that stuff's been linked to cancer
all right let's read some more
let's see
so i see someone mentioning tim
supposedly doesn't drink i've often said
i have like a few drinks per year
a few
yeah but um
they're all because i peer pressure but
now i'm absolutely done you know because
my thing was like i'm not i'm not like i
can't drink it's impossible i'm just
like i prefer not to because i like to
exercise
you know after i when i exercise or
write a song i want to improve i want
protein synthesis alcohol inhibits that
but if i'm like i'm not working out or
whatever and we're all out having a good
time i'll have a beer and then once i
saw what happened on my recovery after
having beer and having wine i was just
like i am never touching that stuff
again like when you can see the actual
results the next day and you're like
whoa
no like all right let's read some more i
think the cal industry the cal smoothie
industry is in bed with these people and
they're convincing you not to drink
things that actually taste good
whatever it is that's healthy food
people gotta
ian stop calling a baby a thing
i'll call your body a thing but you're a
human it no one gets pronouns no one
you can't stop fighting over pronouns
everyone's it
all right
griffin says crazy how the u.s just gave
ukraine 40 billion dollars in military
aid or in other words 60 of russia's
annual military budget wow
yeah we didn't talk about 40 billion was
it 40 billion and and biden was like we
got to give him 33 and then congress was
like let's give him 40. and then it's
like this regular american woman just
goes my baby needs formula and they're
like
bombs
balian says destiny had rikeda on with a
few lawyers from the left and are having
a good debate on this topic from a law
perspective you should have him on again
nick's dope
yeah i'm down absolutely any time that'd
be
cool all right jacob carter says hey
sheamus god bless you i have to ask how
do you feel about dr david wood um i
think i've heard the name i'm not really
familiar with dr david wood
which i've heard the name that's about
it
richard knight says new drinking game
when ian says i don't even know what
that means we all take a shot everyone
will be hammered by the end of the show
you know people always say stuff like
that and it's like i don't think it's a
real i don't think it would really work
you know a drinking water drinking game
based on well people are always like
whenever someone says this or someone
says that and i'm like maybe they said
it like three times in a short period
but they don't say it every show all the
time
all right dragon lady says tim i ordered
emergency food while watching your first
segment today you give good advice on
that i've had it before it was a
lifesaver when i lost my job a few years
ago and couldn't afford food you never
know what might happen folks
i mean yeah for sure they were saying
fragility of society
yeah people don't realize
that like new york it is scary what
would happen if the supply chain just
stopped
people in on that island there'd be no
food a lot of boats a lot of boats
bringing food in
i don't no there's no supply chain
if the supply chain stops that's the
difference right
i'm talking about the roads get shut
down if the i mean but i don't really
don't think you're gonna boats can't
bring enough food you need trucks to
bring it through the city too
all right not my regrets is my wallet my
choice
that's right i get i think
ruben ruben rubin says sheamus please
make an animation of biden chanting
ultra maga in a cult-like setting as a
shadowy society of uh a shadowy specter
of trump grows over a pentagram then in
the end biden will be relieved because
finally he has an actual enemy oh my
goodness a specter of trump
or he you know you should do you know
that you know that thing where they had
r kelly rapping on the holly hologram oh
my god was it r kelly they had like it's
paint of glass on a stage
and they can project a 3d person on the
glass tupac tupac yeah
yeah
yeah but there's a lot of baggage there
so they're like we're going to do a
hologram
you should
biden
puts trump in a hologram to create
something to rally against
come on man look he's over here
omega says horseshoe theory is a post
hoc fallacy authoritarianism is the aim
left and right are two different paths
the same conclusion similar can be said
about libertarianism
in what way that's a path towards oh
left or right libertarianism
i i don't know it's it's it's hard
left libertarianism doesn't scale
right libertarianism has currency to
help a decentralized network expand left
libertarianism of like cooperation and
just like agreements without currency
communal systems doesn't scale it's
important you need
i just don't i don't see it i think it
would no matter what direction you go if
you don't stop and you're just gonna go
all the way you become extreme and
that's the danger extremists are
dangerous you gotta have an open mind
all right let's see what we got here
sleeve zen says my 27 year old daughter
who is perfect was born at 30 weeks the
baby next to her was born at 19 and
thriving 27 years ago why don't they
concentrate on better birth control
i don't know
sheamus to you wait could you repeat
that
you're saying that
her daughter was born at 30 weeks and is
fine oh 27 year old daughter yeah it was
27 years ago that peop babies could be
born seven and a half months
was it in an incubator mm-hmm
or he or she an incubator i guess at
that point they them zimzer yeah
i mean yeah
seven and a half months that's not uh
certainly not a hurricane i've known
people that were born premature they
would call it and then they lived the
first month or so in an incubator
all right that guy says i hope they do
codify row into federal law using
verbiage like shall not be infringed and
red states just do what they want in
restricting access i'd love to see the
left's reaction
then
the republicans should offer that up
shall not be infringed all right
do you agree define infringed right yeah
all right colin h says have you ever
heard of jennifer briny and her podcast
congressional dish please reach out to
her as a guest i believe her work
investigating congress for the last 10
years is the most underappreciated
podcast you can get her work is stellar
well okay i mean that girl's name again
jennifer briny interesting congressional
dish
ben thomas says for sheamus what state
is best for a uk citizen to move to i've
got tim's uh and jack's opinion now i
want yours my two front runners are
texas and florida if you're from the uk
then stay out there's no good
straightforward
i would say
if if you're asking me i can't speak
specifically to the british experience
and what might translate to life in
america
but if i were gonna start over in any
state i think i would pick florida
i wouldn't do florida why not why not
tim it's a purple state
that's why i would make it red i'd go
there boom every vocal it is i think
getting redder for sure a lot of people
are moving there i do think it's a good
opportunity for someone who wants to you
know push back on the establishment to
go
me personally i think west virginia is
the place to be mountain mama there are
there's a
there's an opportunity for bringing good
jobs to a more sparsely populated state
with a lot of good people here and i
think great i i looked at florida i'm
like it's it's massively developed they
call miami the capital of latin america
and i'm like it's great they're doing
great things for sure yeah what's wrong
with latin america no i think it's not i
think it's fantastic florida's doing i
want to bring new jobs and new
opportunity to west virginia and start
building culture and
bringing economic power to people who
share values that i with me like mor
liberty personal responsibility etc no i
hear you i love west virginia um i also
love georgia where i spent several years
of my life but i'm sort of more thinking
along the lines of if i were to start
over and go somewhere else where would
it be i gotta say florida this one's for
you seamus loratak says sheamus 10 years
ago when i was pro-abortion i became
pregnant and got an abortion at 22 weeks
it was the biggest mistake of my life is
it possible for such a sin to be
forgiven if so will i get to meet him in
heaven that's a really good question so
there is no sin which is greater than
christ's sacrifice on the cross if you
are truly repentant of your sin
and also if you forgive the sins of
others that have been committed against
you you can absolutely repent of that
sin um and confess i
would encourage meeting with and
discussing with a catholic priest if i
understand there have been some in the
past stipulations about whether you
could be
forgiven directly by a priest or whether
there would need to be forgiveness by
bishop if i'm not mistaken but really
yes because i think it incurred because
it incurred excommunication uh oh
i'm not i want to double check here uh i
know that for the year of mercy pope
francis basically extended it so that
priests could let me take one second to
google this so i can give her to me well
let me just well i think it's any crime
against human i think it's any crime
that ends up killing a person but i just
i want to actually google this so i can
be sure
about these details and give her no
more concrete i'm just saying like the
idea that there needs to be a
hierarchical nature of the church to
determine whether you could be forgiven
for something you're a pendant for seems
a little odd to me well i don't think
it's the um i don't think it's a
question of determining
whether you can be forgiven i i need to
double i think it's just a question of
like who has the authority to forgive in
that circumstance because if you've
incurred next communication i think
there's a different process
for the forgiveness but like i said i
really want to double check on this this
is the first i heard of the year of
mercy the extraordinary jubilee of mercy
is this is from 2015 to 2016. what was
it exactly like they just made it easier
to forgive yeah so i really want to try
to pull up the details so i'm not giving
it i don't know about this question i
just
there was a um
an incident where there was a centennial
at a church where if you walked through
the arches all sins had been forgiven
and it was a serious risk to the
creation of the universe because if
locally loki and bartleby crossed
through they would be forgiven of their
sins and allowed back into heaven which
would then prove god fallible and result
in the undoing of the universe that
makes more sense
no idea what you're doing now i'm
talking about dogma oh i didn't see it
the kevin smith shout out to kevin smith
that was the plot of the rats last night
spoiler alert on the 30 year old movie
he hasn't seen
rats is awesome come on man
yeah and uh uh in dogma that's basically
what happens the church is like we're
gonna forgive all sins loki and bartleby
were you know banished from heaven and
if they get forgiven they can go to
heaven and that would prove god fallible
which would undo the universe i think
it's a funny movie and then they were
just like there's a point where
i think in the beginning it's ben
affleck and matt damon and he's like why
would why would some priests claiming
this be true
actually allow us in and then he's like
what you hold true on earth we hold true
in heaven or something like that
it's a funny movie but i think it's like
an atheist's perspective on religion
you know so they make a bunch of points
that are just like
not relevant i think to it but it's a
funny movement in the list jay and
silent bob
all right let's see what we got
steven brooks says my cousin can't
medically have kids but she has always
dreamed of being a mother she adopted
amelia just two months ago in texas
emilia was slated to be aborted but the
band stopped it my cousin has a daughter
today only because of the texas law
that's so wonderful wow yeah it is just
really shocking to me when they're like
that that that impoverished child
shouldn't live that's so and they're and
and what they do is there's a meme i saw
where it's pro-lifers saying we believe
in life you can't you can't abort that
baby and then it's like nine months
later and she's holding the baby and
they're like we're not gonna provide you
with anything you're on your own you you
lose or whatever and i'm like
you know it's a silly argument because
the same argument applies that you're
basically saying what like that baby
should be dead
you know it's like by all means
show the conservatives screaming you'll
get no handouts you you lazy person and
then at the same time show the the
liberals screaming and that baby should
be dead
yeah yeah well i've said this before
look when witnessing to child poverty
the pro-lifer thinks the problem is the
poverty the pro-choicer thinks the
problem is the child yeah it's really
just a crazy argument when they're like
if you're poor the baby should die and
i'm like oh man
i don't know about that that's pretty
that's pretty extreme yeah well it's
like it's it's not like they're saying
the baby was born now kill it they're
saying the baby should never have been
allowed to be alive because you're poor
not even giving it's like a chance like
that's a pretty they're like
conservatives will will punish you for
having the baby and won't support your
baby's life abort it
i'm like i don't know like that sounds
kind of weird dude no some of my
greatest role models grew up really
really poor some of them in the deep jim
crow south and i just wanted to say um i
think that uh oh i saw a super chat
earlier that was like you know if a
mother if a father can get rid of his
parental responsibility and abortion is
outlawed can a mother do the same thing
yes it's called adoption you can give
your child up for adoption you can place
your child on the step of a fire
department and you don't have to take
responsibility for it these are options
that no one ever talks about can a man
do that a man probably not no feminist
would not want him to be able to do that
that's the thing like the woman can
literally give the baby away without
telling the guy right but the guy cannot
absolve himself from responsibility
unless the woman says so so think by
this way what would happen if a woman
had a baby
and then put the baby on the steps of a
fire department without telling the guy
he could he could file a suit for
custody but the woman still got to
choose to give it away right
the guy doesn't have any choice to
remove involvement it's a big big leap
of trust with women i mean that's you
really got to kind of realize how
important women are the man has to trust
that the woman has the best intentions
of the baby and the husband and the man
yeah wait i wanted to rep
to what that person said that it was the
texas abortion ban is the reason why
your was it your sister has now a kid
cousin has a kid uh even if the band
hadn't gone through if your cousin
really wanted to adopt a baby she would
have
nothing would have stopped her there's
there's a isn't there like uh um
a backlog of parents who want to adopt
that can't well maybe it would have been
more challenging but i'm sure she would
have been haven't these people watched
30 rock
where liz lemon is desperately trying to
adopt and it's very difficult and they
they're like are trying to prevent her
from doing it this is actually true to
life because the adoption process needs
to be overhauled it's incredibly
expensive it takes incredibly long time
and so many people want to adopt babies
many people who can't have kids don't
want to do ivf ivf is super expensive
but so is adoption what are you supposed
to do remember on 30 rock when tina
fey's character
confesses that she tells her friends she
voted for obama but she actually voted
for mccain
i thought that was funny because i'm
like is that joke supposed to be
relatable or funny to these people
because back then it was it was a joke
and i was like ah that's funny nowadays
they'd be like what
how dare you make a character all right
the hylian juggalo says neil
shusterman's book series from 2007
called unwind predicted a second civil
war and where we are going in regards to
abortion given we're talking about
aborting born babies get set for teen
body harvesting please read the synopsis
wild
remember on south park
when uh eric's mom tries to get the
doctor to give her an abortion and he's
like how far along are you and she's
like the 493rd trimester or something
like that like some ridiculous number
he's like wait what
she tried
yeah he's like so your kid's 10 years
old yep the jaded kriegsman says as a
minnesotan i can tell you that we might
actually see waltz lose crazy crime
levels crt in schools and down economy
might finally turn the suburbs against
the dfl teachers union mafia in
minnesota good well well and that's
that's again we're still very much
dealing with the with the effects of of
those rights because people just saw how
far they could take it and so now it's
like happening on a low intensity level
with because we're seeing the the smash
and grabs like this spontaneous looting
that happens with like five people and
then they all run out and because
there's no consequences for that
all right dylan layton says i work
retail and a customer came in and
lectured me on how the z on samsung's
marketing
boards are offensive the customer
equated it to a swastika of the letter z
the hyper politization of society is
rampant
yeah well you know that's uh russia so
nona to give says after daryl davis
tried to get tim keller he's been a
minister in new york city for 30 plus
years so should have a good
should have good cultural insights as a
topic of discussion how to forgive when
i deserve it apology is not forthcoming
hardwick says for ian does the media
gaslight and get things wrong most the
time two why do you believe the media
about kent state rotc building burned
police attacked day before day of
students through rocks and fireworks at
national guard
oh yeah yeah the the kids were throwing
stuff at the or maybe the adults i guess
at that point were throwing stuff at the
cops before that the law before they
fired i don't know if the media's
gaslight i mean i imagine that they are
from the evidence i've seen throwing
rocks at national guard doesn't warrant
a lethal response that killed bystanders
that's why was such a tragedy
john galt says tim's right we are
already in a civil war it is being
fought by a law fair culture and
institutional change occasionally it
turns to hot war and open violence the
only person on offense against the
postmodern leftists is ron desantis
yup he's like the first republican i've
ever heard of who's like i am going to
do things and not just react to things
but i don't want to soften the word war
i think you sheamus brought this up a
couple weeks ago not to soften these
terms because if we were really in a
civil war there would be a lot more dead
bodies yeah there's no civil war right
now it's it's like conflict civil
conflict you're seeing well it's it's
civil strife yeah that's what uh stephen
maher said when you get i think what do
you say more than 70 deaths in a
political context per year you're in
civil strife the challenge though is the
expansion of population density and
population growth so when that number
was
set were they looking at populations
that were 20 the size of the united
states
as the population grows we need to look
at per capita
how many how many political killings per
capita to become civil servants and also
frequency because if it happens all in
one night and then there's like nine
months of peace then that's not really
strife there was like a
you know what it happens it was fiery
but mostly peaceful yeah just keep an
eye out for a caning in congress okay
because when that happens we're gonna be
like okay hold on everybody is the
canary in the coal mine right there yeah
there's gonna be a duel by the way i
found some information that i want to
give to that super chatter from earlier
so i wanted to make sure to get this
from a couple of sources from what i'm
reading um at the end of 2016 or at the
end of the year of mercy pope francis
actually um
extended
this ability so any as far as i
understand you can go to confession and
confess something like that to a priest
so i would i would absolutely encourage
her to do so like i said there's no
sin that you have committed that is so
uh horrible that god will will not
forgive you and he's given you the
sacraments to be able to receive that
absolution so god bless you and i will
keep you in my prayers all right we'll
get a couple more in here hb brian says
james o'keefe just dropped fbi
whistleblower
that sounds spicy yeah we'll check that
one out
all right jordan bushaw says i was born
in ukraine and adopted by my mom who was
born in the u.s i thank god for her and
that ukraine seems to value life more
than the us love you mom adoption is
always an option
my friends if you have not already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show anywhere you can
on social media if you do like it head
over to timcast.com become a member
click that sign up button we're gonna
have a members only show coming up it's
gonna be published at 11 p.m we're going
to talk about chaos catastrophe the
apocalypse we're probably going to swear
a whole lot it's good fun and as a
member you're helping support alternate
social media i'm sorry alternate big
tech infrastructure
we use rumble infrastructure for the
website so support businesses that are
getting away from the silicon valley
stuff i know we're on youtube but we
have we are we are continuing the
process we use rumble video player for
members only stuff so the website is
running on rumble we've gotten more
announcements coming in the next couple
of weeks because we are actively not
only has ian been working on
infrastructure stuff but we are actually
implementing more infrastructure changes
to get away from big tech and silicon
valley with your support as members you
can follow the show at tim cast irl you
can follow me personally at tim cast
julio you want to shout anything out
yeah no i mean i think thanks for having
me again and and yeah i i really hope
that you know for people who who read it
i mean it took a lot of work into it i
mean it was uh
certainly a labor of love and and it's
kind of crazy that i'm a published
author now i never thought i would do
that so i just hope people read it and
enjoy it soon to be new york times
best-selling author i mean i don't care
about
it
i mean
soon to be okay accept it
if they don't throttle it because you
know they've been known to yeah
well matt walsh is a best-selling
children's author and
lgbtq yeah good for him yeah good for
him sheamus is an award-winning animator
that's i've not won a single i award you
oh my gosh i'm a newborn congratulations
the
that's what i figured well this is very
i like that the thing is sort of torn
off the clip is torn off because i'm you
know well it represents the realism
that's right exactly work exactly
because i'm i'm i'm i am causing some
threat to the system breaking things
down people are right people don't
realize this that sheamus actually draws
by hand all of these cells and then he
uses a camera from the 1930s mounted
over a table to animate the show so
basically yeah so so what happens is i
um i draw all the pictures with
permanent markers so i don't get a
second chance and then i color them all
in and then we we photograph pictures of
them and then um the animators who i've
hired promptly just delete all of that
and make something that looks way better
every time and if you want to see that
final product check out freedom tunes
we're going to be uploading a video
tomorrow i think you guys will really
enjoy it we pump out a cartoon every
single thursday sometimes sometimes on
tuesdays as well so hit that
notification bell i love you all have a
wonderful day i'll echo what tim said
we're fervently building some uh free
software copy left agpl3 software is
what i mean by free software it's the
licensing uh it's it's badass dude i
looked at the ux today we had a meeting
earlier it's looking really cool so it
will give you the opportunity to upload
videos to rumble youtube your own
personal server and then you've got it
it's just like a youtube dashboard style
thing but other people have theirs and
then they can see your stuff you can see
theirs you can you can it's like we're
creating web 3 front end technology and
probably back end technology too i'm
really excited to be part of it thank
you guys for working on it with me thank
you guys for coming i'll see you next
time
you guys may wonder if i have any
thoughts during the show that i don't
voice and i definitely do so i have
started a little sub stack where i put
some of my ideas on paper nothing very
profound so far i wrote about the
formula crisis and the other day i was
talking about why women use that weird
fake squeaky laughing voice when they
make horrible declarations on tick tock
so those are my two articles so far
they're excellent i recommend going and
following me on substance lydia
lighterman at sub stack or substack.com
i don't know what it is yet look me up
over there anyway you guys may also
follow me on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchlits in case you were wondering
what we're doing with all of your money
when you become a member head over to
chickencitylive.com
which is just our chicken city youtube
channel and
scroll down to our latest video that's
right tim cast has released its first
anime
insane rooster fight at chicken city
starring roberto and roberto jr
featuring the voice of tim poole as
roberto jr and danny polishchuck as
roberto senior in an epic anime battle
which will rock your world
and uh head over to timcast.com we'll
see you in the members only segment
thanks for hanging out
you